bien mes chers collègues je vous invite
à rejoindre vos places
nous allons donc débuter notre réunion
de commission et singulièrement
l'audition
de deux ministres mises à l'intérieur
d'outre-mer monsieur Darmanin et puis le
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion Monsieur Olivier du socle
ils sont cet après-midi devant notre
commission au moment où le texte sur
l'immigration va venir en débat
quelque temps quand même puisque je
rappelle que la science publique est
prévue à partir du 27 mars prochain mais
qu'évidemment préalablement nous aurons
le rapport de nos rapporteurs nos deux
rapporteurs madame Jourda et Monsieur
Philippe bonnecarraire en commission et
singulièrement un certain nombre
d'amendements que j'imagine en
préparation monsieur les ministres je
tiens à vous signaler que nous sommes en
retransmission directe sur Public Sénat
et prenons sur le site internet du Sénat
ce qui fait que cette audition a un
caractère qui va public au-delà même de
notre nos éminents commissaires qui sont
présents
et je vais sans tarder vous donner la
parole dans l'ordre que vous souhaitez
c'est peut-être vous monsieur Darmanin
qui débuterez
ensuite je proposerai à Madame Jourda et
Monsieur Bonnecarrère de vous poser des
questions nous allons vous y répondrez
et puis les collègues qui voudront
s'exprimer le front bien sûr tout en se
signalant comme d'habitude
auprès de nous pour qu'on puisse
enregistrer les demandes de parole voilà
merci de votre présence et monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cher Olivier madame monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis très heureux avec mon
collègue et Amy Olivier du site d'être
devant votre commission pour commencer
l'étude du texte proposé par le
gouvernement sur la situation migratoire
et sur les moyens que le gouvernement
pourrait se donner à la suite de la Love
Me y reviendront puisque ce n'est pas un
texte là de moyen c'est un texte
législatif mais les voyants ont été
votés par le Sénat notamment je remercie
sur la loi de modernisation du ministère
de l'Intérieur pour essayer d'être au
rendez-vous des capacités que nous
donnons dans la révolution pour les
préfectures comme pour l'intégration
pour évoquer cette situation migratoire
que le Sénat depuis longtemps appellent
de ses vœux une réponse forte et de
réponse évidemment au rendez-vous des
enjeux ces enjeux ils sont très
importants je vois d'abord rappeler que
la situation internationale c'est-à-dire
les guerres et les dictatures qui se
multiplient sur les théâtres du monde
les persécutions qu'elles soient
religieuses ou sexuelles les difficultés
économiques et sociales que notre pays
est
évidemment est partagé par beaucoup de
pays en développement notamment depuis
le covid et puis bien sûr le changement
climatique font peser sur l'Europe et
sur la France une pression migratoire
très importante
tellement importante que elle ne se
vérifie pas depuis ces derniers mois ou
depuis la situation du covid comme je le
lis parfois je voudrais souligner
demande d'asile a été multipliée par
deux en disant et que la demande d'asile
a été multiplie par 3 depuis 2007 rien
que de l'année 2022 qui continue cette
augmentation des immigrations et
notamment de l'immigration dites de
protection la hausse de toute l'Union
européenne des demandes d'Asie en 2022
c'est plus
61%, je pourrais constater qu'en France
ce n'est que je mets évidemment des
guillemets que
31%, mais nous avons atteint le pic
historique de 2019 138000 demandes
d'asile en 2022 et donc nous
retrouverons évidemment des chiffres qui
correspondent aux crises migratoires
précédentes et rien ne peut penser que
cela s'arrêtera dans dans les mois et
dans les années qui viennent pour tout
le continent européen
la comparaison avec les années
fin des années 90 et début 2000 n'a plus
beaucoup de sens je rappelle que la
plupart des pays d'immigration et
demandeur d'asile par exemple ce soit la
Syrie la Libye l'Afghanistan mais aussi
tous les pays de la bande saelo
saharienne n'était pas dans le chaos
politique et terroriste que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui la France comme
l'Europe avait des relations
dilomatiques fortes avec ces pays ce qui
n'est plus le cas pour une partie
d'entre eux je ne parle évidemment pas
de ce qui se passe encore très récemment
en Iran on a aussi pensé pendant très
longtemps dans les politiques publiques
que les gouvernements menés qui soient
droits de gauche que le développement
économique notamment du continent
africain frederait l'immigration et
force cette constater aujourd'hui que
chacun le constate que le développement
économique du continent africain
notamment ne freine pas l'immigration
mais la tendance à même l'encourager
puisqu'une partie de la classe devenue
moyenne dans certains pays d'immigration
historiques fait que vers l'Europe vers
les États-Unis vers l'Occident les gens
soient prennent les moyens du
déménagement défauts déménager une
partie de leurs enfants ou de leurs
parents pour qu'il trouve un avenir
meilleur il y a donc une situation
difficile à obtenir pour l'Europe à la
fois des crises qui font naître des
départs et puis en même temps un
développement qui fait aussi naître des
départs pousser aussi par une
démographie importante
le débat en France comme partout en
Europe n'est pas donc d'être pour ou
contre l'immigration immigration est un
fait c'est une réalité qui touche tous
les pays quel que soit le régime
politique quel que soit l'opinion de
leur dirigeants et comme le disait le
Général de Gaulle il n'y a pas de
politique en dehors des réalités c'est
donc c'est la réalité que nous devons
regarder en face en revanche un grand
continent comme l'Europe un grand pays
comme la France doit répondre à trois
questions ces trois questions sont sans
doute le ne grandir de notre débat et
les 27 articles que propose de ce projet
de loi apporte je l'espère pour vous un
début de réponse quelle émigration veut
ton
quelle exigence demande aux étrangers
qui viennent sur notre sol et quels
moyens nous donnons-nous pour appliquer
la politique qui répond aux deux
premières questions
j'entends parfois encore une loi c'est
vrai que depuis 1986 une vingtaine de
lois ont été adoptées par le Parlement
français
je rappelle qu'une seule loi seulement a
été adoptée pendant le calcana du
président de la République celle de la
loi colombes qui a permis notamment de
diminuer les délais de l'OFPRA quasiment
par deux puisque désormais c'est à peu
près en quatre mois que l'OFPRA
regardait demande de d'asile je
remarquerai que sous les autres
présidents notamment la présidence du
président Hollande en 5 ans trois lois
ont été adoptées il est pas tout à fait
anormal que les gouvernements et le
Parlement s'intéressent et légifère sur
cette question très importante de
l'immigration d'abord pour les
changements internationaux notamment
européen beaucoup de lois faisaient la
conséquence de directives qu'il fallait
évidemment traduire
législativement mais aussi parce que
l'immigration est protéiforme venant de
pays très différents pour des causes de
très différents et il n'est pas tout à
fait anormal que les parlements et que
les gouvernements s'adaptent à cette
situation par nature changeante
quelle est la structure de la migration
en France elle connaît un défaut je
crois si on veut répondre à la première
question quelle migration veut-on elle
est trop familiale et pas assez
professionnelle elle n'est pas assez
qualifiée et elle est trop subie et pas
assez choisi avant toute chose je veux
ici dire même si ce n'est pas l'objet de
nos débats que la question d'immigration
ne pourrait pas se résoudre en tant
qu'adré pas réglé au niveau européen qui
nous paraît être je crois le bon niveau
pour répondre aux questions que se pose
tous les pays européens je veux ici dire
que cela présence française Union
européenne nous avons beaucoup avancé il
faut désormais que cela présidence
suédoise et avant le Parlement européen
qui sera réélu au mois de juin prochain
nous terminions l'accord qui avait été
mené par la présidence française qui
repose sur quatre grands projets le
premier c'est évidemment la prévention
des départs on voit l'occasion d'en
reparler qui ne passe pas que par le
développement qui peut passer évidemment
par le développement mais qui passe
aussi par le départ au sens littéral du
terme et notamment la prise en mer et le
drame qui ont connu les reconnu
évidemment les migrants au large
l'Italie nous rappelle évidemment que
c'est drame ne sont des drames avant
tout pour les personnes qui quittent
leur pays dans des conditions absolument
affreuses c'est prévention de départ
doit se faire avec les pays et l'Europe
doit être unie pour porter le même
discours avec avec tous ces pays qui
doivent faire leur travail
d'intégration de population et de non
encouragements de l'immigration
irrégulière ce qui est parfois le cas le
deuxième sujet c'est évidemment une
politique commune de l'Union européenne
dans les visas réadmissions il ne peut
pas y avoir de visa octroyés si les
réadmissions ce qu'on appelle les
laisser passer consulaires la politique
de retour n'est pas au rendez-vous de
ces pays malheureusement lorsqu'un pays
comme la France par exemple prend des
décisions courageuses de restriction de
visa si d'autres pays européens
devraient pas d'autres pays européennes
d'autres pays européens donnent ces
visas et ainsi vous perdez à la fois
votre action de restriction à des visas
tout en ayant évidemment pas gagné sur
votre politique de réadmission puisque
la vie européenne fait qu’avisa octroyer
dans un pays de l'Union européenne ne
s'applique pour l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne il faut donc absolument que
l'Europe sorte de son égoïsme et adopte
une politique commune une diplomatie
commune en matière de visa et admission
et que avec les pays qui sont les pays
de départ s'il n'acceptent pas le retour
des personnes que nous voulons plus sur
notre sol européen il n'y ait pas dans
aucun des pays de politique de visa
donnée cette politique a été adoptée par
le Conseil européen il faut évidemment
qu'elle se traduise en termes législatif
en termes diplomatique évidemment le
troisième sujet c'est la protection de
nos frontières les étrangers qui
arrivent sur le sol européen ne sont pas
tous enregistrés nous ne connaissons pas
toujours l'exact
identité de leur état civil pour plein
de raisons évidemment nous ne
connaissons pas leur vie et notamment
leur âge qui évidemment pose des
problèmes de reconnaissance d'adultes ou
de mineurs que les sénateurs ici
connaissent bien et nous connaissons pas
souvent leur histoire et notamment leur
histoire du point de vue des services de
renseignements nous avons adopté deux
textes extrêmement importants pour la
vie de l'Union européenne et donc pour
la France le règlement screening c'est à
dire l'enregistrement porte de l'Europe
et le règlement Eurodac ces textes ont
été adoptés par le Conseil européen il
faut désormais que la Commission libérée
du Parlement européen et que le
Parlement européen les acceptes pour que
nous puissions en effet avoir enfin une
politique de frontière commune et
d'enregistrement commun et enfin
quatrième point qui n'a pas été adopté
par le Conseil européen mais qui
mériterait d'être largement poussé par
les chefs d'État c'est une politique
unique de l'asile puisque aujourd'hui
les conditions de trois de l'asile sont
différents entre les pays et on pourrait
évoquer que ces différences jouent
évidemment sur l'ensemble de nos
politiques migratoires et encouragent
parfois à sa zone de personnes à venir
alors qu'il ne mérite pas cet asile qui
n'ont pas droit à cet asile et donc
utilisent l'asile à des fins détournée
d'immigration irrégulière chacun le sait
une fois qu'on a dit qu'une grande
partie des sujets étaient européens il
n'est pas classique de s'arrêter ici de
mon Parlement français et évidemment il
y a des dispositions que peut prendre un
pays dans le cadre des règles
européennes et de la Constitution telle
qu'elle est en vigueur puisqu'il s'agit
messieurs les sénateurs d'un projet doit
ordinaire et qui m'appartient pas de
revoir la politique conventionnelle ou
constitutionnelle de notre pays à ma
modeste place je veux ici souligner les
quatre grands points d'intérêt du projet
de loi le premier est d'abord une
simplification générale du droit qui a
été validée par deux hautes autorités
monsieur le Président d'abord votre
rapport adopté à l'unanimité de la
commission qu'il a contribué à le
produire mais aussi par le Conseil des
tâches accords à ceux de constater que
le projet de loi du gouvernement a connu
sur cette question extrêmement complexe
cela simplification générale du droit
appliqué au contentieux des étrangers le
Conseil d'État a bien voulu donner à
quitus important au gouvernement toutes
les mesures que nous proposons sont donc
constitutionnelles a priori et nous en
félicitons parce que beaucoup
d'interrogations existaient et notamment
monsieur le président
dans les propositions que vous avez
formulées je retiendrai facilement 4
très rapide d'abord la réforme du
contentieux en tant que tel le passage
de 12 procédures à 4 procédures
c'est-à-dire la division par 3 du nombre
de procédures que peuvent utiliser les
étrangers avant d'être expulsés du
territoire national je rappelle que 50%
du compte ensuite tribunal administratif
c'est le droit des étrangers 40% des
cours appels administratives le trot
d'autres droits administratif est
complètement bouchée si j'ose dire par
ce contentieux qui est désormais long
illisible et qui détournent finalement
l'efficacité de l'État qu'est-ce qui se
passe la plupart du temps lorsque un
préfet prend un arrêté de reconduite à
la frontière enfin le fameux
qtf désormais bien connu je crois par
une partie de nos compatriotes des
recours sans cesse peuvent être formulés
détaillerai pas ici les sujets je pense
que vous rapporter le feront sans doute
dans les discussions que nous aurons
plus amplement et nous pouvons attendre
parfois un an et demi deux ans avant
d'avoir une réponse définitive qui
valide la position de l'État elle est
souvent valider à 70% des casques qui
est quand même plutôt des bonnes
décisions si j'ose dire du point de vue
d'autorité et préfectoral mais entre
temps depuis deux ans que ces
contentieux existent l'étranger a pu
soit trouver un travail de façon
illégale et parfois de toute façon
légale le ministre du Travail il
reviendra notre propre incurie
administrative ou de la part de
personnes employeur voyou il a pu se
marier avoir en tout cas des relations
juridiques on va dire sur le territoire
de la République avoir des enfants les
inscrire à l'école et donc au bout d'un
moment la vie privée est familiale fait
que le temps a joué contre la décision
originale de l'État et parce que nous
n'avons pas été vite et parce que les
contentieux sont trop nombreux on en est
à des situations improbables depuis de
très nombreuses années où l'État a
finalement raison et peu expulsé les
personnes même lorsqu'elle a laissé
passer consulaire mais ne peut
finalement pas le faire puisque le temps
long a joué pour la vie privée et
familiale de cette même personne donc la
réforme du contentieux est vraiment le
nœud gordien pour être beaucoup plus
rapide pour réduire drastiquement les
délais et c'est évidemment un point très
important de ce de ce projet de
l'extension évidemment à la vidéo
audience est quelque chose extrêmement
important aussi et elle fait évidemment
contestation de la part d'un certain
nombre de personnes mais nous pensons
que le droit c'est beaucoup numérisé et
que ces vidéos audience nous permettront
également de traduire ces réductions
drastiques des délais dans la réalité la
proposition du juge unique à la CNDA qui
permet de d'être beaucoup plus efficace
dans la rapidité des décisions prises
par le juge de la Cour nationale de
droit d'asile si nous avons dans la
Colomb diminué à 4 mois 4 mois et demi
l'étude d'une demande d'asile c'est
désormais
une moyenne 9 mois parfois un an et demi
peut-être même plus lorsque l'appel est
formé devant la CNDA et donc nous devons
absolument drastiquement réduire là
aussi c'est ces recours pour pouvoir non
pas juger sur le fond différemment il ne
s'agit pas ici de proposer des critères
différents pour l'asile constitutionnel
mais de pouvoir donner plus de moyens et
de meilleure organisation pour juger
plus rapidement pour savoir si quelqu'un
a le droit à l'asile en France
vis-à-vis de leur employeur vis-à-vis de
leur famille et vis-à-vis évidemment du
droit tout court mais aussi
en pêche sans doute de voir soit les
grosses efforts d'intégration que l'État
doit accompagner avec les moyens que
nous allons lui octroyer mais aussi
mieux vérifier les dossier des primo
arrivants puisque aujourd'hui si je
devais résumer nous passons beaucoup de
temps à demander des documents
administratifs il y a des gens qui
depuis très nombreuses années parfois
des je pense aux Chibani qui ont 75 80
85 90 ans à qui on demande encore de
venir en préfecture déposer un dossier
que ça fait 60 ans qui sont sur le
territoire national ils ont parfois été
décorés par notre pays sous les
courageux pendant pendant nos guerres et
ne pas essayer de temps pour vérifier le
casier judiciaire ou la bonne
intégration la personne qui vient
d'arriver sur le territoire national
j'aurai l'occasion de détailler cette
réforme profonde du fonctionnement de
nos préfectures et des par les moyens
octroyés d'ailleurs par le projet de loi
de finances que vous avez bien voulu
adopter ça permettra monsieur le
Président je sais que vous y êtes
attaché d'adopter si le Sénat le
souhaite fameuse mesure dite du 360
degrés puisque ça nous permettra
évidemment avec cette révolution des
préfectures de faire que quand quelqu'un
déposera une demande ce sera à l'état de
vérifier l'intégralité des titres
auxquels il a droit de dire un nom
définitif pour tous les titres bien sûr
et de pas avoir cette répétition de
dossiers plus des mesures de
simplification dans le droit du travail
que présentera le ministre du soft le
deuxième point après la simplification
drastique du droit des étrangers c'est
le renforcement considérable des
exigences d'intégration que demande que
demandons aux étrangers le gouvernement
dans de façon tout à fait réglementaire
depuis que je suis ministre de
l'Intérieur a considérablement augmenté
les exigences pour devenir français pour
la naturalisation d'ailleurs je constate
qu'il y a à peu près 30% de
naturalisation donnée en moins en 5 ans
notre pays dans ce paradoxe un peu
particulier où il y a plus étrangers sur
le sol national d'où le texte que nous
proposons est moins de gens qui
deviennent français pourquoi parce que
entretien d'assimilation exigences du
niveau linguistique de passage avec un
entretien parfois plusieurs entretiens
devant les agents de préfecture fait que
moins de gens deviennent français parce
que les exigences sont beaucoup plus
fortes que ce n'était encore 5 ou 10 ans
il n'y a pas de d'articles sur le code
nationalité dans le projet que nous
présentons il s'agit intégralement du
droit des étrangers et non pas de ceux
qui peuvent devenir français mais nous
souhaitons appliquer puisque là c'est
législatif à ceux qui ont des titres des
séjours sur le territoire national qui
pourrait en avoir les mêmes exigences ou
quasiment les exigences par Robotis que
nous le demandons à ceux qui vont
devenir français ça passe par trois
grands sujets le premier c'est
évidemment la langue
l'une des révolutions de ce projet de
loi c'est de passer d'une obligation de
moyen une obligation de résultat pour
toute personne qui aura à titre de
séjour ou qui a déjà un titre de séjour
puisque ça concerne évidemment aussi le
stock pardon de ce mauvais mot des
étrangers qui sont sur notre sol
national c'est-à-dire à peu près 300 000
titres par an
pour toute personne qui donc un titre de
séjour pourrait avoir un titre de séjour
long sur le territoire national donc pas
visa de court séjour pour les gens qui
viendraient faire passer quelques jours
de vacances chacun leur a compris l'idée
de ce projet de loi c'est de
conditionner l'octroi de ce titre de
séjour à un critère supplémentaire qui
est la réussite d'un examen de français
le ministre du Travail dira sans doute
que déjà va entre 20 et 25% de personnes
qui sont réguliers sur le territoire
national comprennent extrêmement mal le
français ce qui évidemment empêche
beaucoup le travail et beaucoup
d'intégration mais cette exigence
désormais de l'examen de réussite de
français c'est évidemment quelque chose
qui contribuera très largement à
répondre à la première question quelle
migration voulons-nous une migration qui
parle et qui comprennent notre langue
c'est évidemment une révolution aussi
pour les services des préfectures la
deuxième exigence d'intégration c'est
une disposition qui est inspirée
directement de la loi dite séparatisme
que la majorité sénatoriale a également
voté je n'en aussi qui confine à
effectivement demander à ce que les
étrangers qui sont sur des titres de
séjour long là aussi il s'agit pas de
regarder les gens qui ont un visa
touristique bien évidemment mais titre
de séjour long un engagement de respect
des valeurs de la République son emblème
hymne national le devis de la République
le caractère laïque de la République la
liberté religieuse et bien sûr
l'orientation sexuelle cette personne
qui viendra sur notre sol devra signer
son engagement assez respecté ces
principes de la République qu'est-ce que
cela entraînerait s'il ne les signes pas
il n'aurait pas de ces jours on peut
imaginer que beaucoup d'entre le signe
quand même ça entraînerait le fait que
par exemple aujourd'hui les mises à
l'intérieur ne peut pas retirer son
titre de séjour un homme qui refuse
d'être soigné par une femme chez un
médecin et demain ce sera le cas si la
disposition évidemment est adoptée par
le Parlement il y a la poursuite pénale
ça c'était la loi dite séparatisme il y
a le retrait administratif du titre de
séjour ça c'est le texte que je propose
aujourd'hui
et puis il y a le troisième point sur
l'intégration qui est intéressant par le
travail mais je laisserai le ministre du
Travail évidemment développé ce sujet je
voudrais dire que pour mettre être au
rendez-vous des exigences d'intégration
que nous demandons vous avez voté une
enveloppe extrêmement importante dans la
loi de modernisation du ministère de
l'intérieur parce que vous avez augmenté
de 25 % les crédits de l'intégration
c'est la plus grande hausse des
criminations qu'a connue la République
106 millions d'euros pour les trois
prochaines années nous pensons que c'est
suffisant pour être au rendez-vous de
ces exigences c'est évidemment
extrêmement important de le souligner
devant le Parlement après la
simplification drastique du contentieux
après les exigences qui passent
notamment par la langue et par le
respect dans la République des étrangers
je veux souligner le troisième point
très important de ce projet de loi c'est
l'expulsion des étrangers menaçant
l'ordre public pour faire très simple
c'est la fin de la fin de la double
peine où le rétablissement de d'une
certaine double peine que vous le
souhaitez et la lutte contre les
filières d'immigration irrégulière
si je commence par la filière
d'immigrations régulières donc qu'est-ce
qu'on essaie de faire dans ce projet de
loi c'est donner les armes désormais au
préfet au ministère de l'Intérieur il y
a la justice de pouvoir lutter contre le
continuum pour utiliser un mot que
chacun connaît ici de l'immigration
irrégulière organisée malheureusement
nous constatons que
utilisons la misère des personnes des
femmes d'enfants de personnes
étrangers dans toute de toute nature les
passeurs sont de véritables criminels et
sont responsables à la fois évidemment
la situation d'immigrations régulières
que nous connaissons mais aussi des
drames qu'on a connu à caler comme au
large de l'Italie encore extrêmement je
l'ai dit d'abord ça renforcement
extrêmement fort de sanctions contre les
patrons les employeurs voyous qui
embauchent les personnes irrégulières je
laisserai le ministre du Travail
l'évoquer c'est ensuite notre propre
accurerie administrative qui est visée
avec la fin notamment du statut
d'auto-entrepreneur que l'on peut créer
même lorsqu'on a pas de papier en règle
et qui crée je crois que chacun le const
des trappes nous-mêmes à emploi et donc
à régularisation ou à Nini ni
régularisable ni expulsable je laisserai
également le ministre du Travail en
parler ensuite c'est une peine de prison
extrêmement forte passant ainsi de
délits Hakim le crime de passeur de 20
ans de prison pour ceux qui se rendent
coupables de passage d'immigrés
clandestins si évidemment cela entraîne
la mort de ces personnes et de 15 ans si
ça ne s'entraîne pas la mort c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui le minimum des
condamnations des passeurs que nous
retrouvons et pour lequel la
préjudiciaire et des polices
internationales grâce à Europole font de
magnifiques affaires ne sont pas la
hauteur du crime que nous constatons
puisque c'est entre 1 et 7 ans selon les
jugements des tribus d'eau le passage
dans un crime dans le code pénal on le
doit au garder ça je le remercie et je
pense que ce serait une mesure
extrêmement attendue par les polices
judiciaires et par la police aux
frontières et c'est également lutter
contre les marchands de sommeil une
disposition est extrêmement importante
dans ce projet de loi j'en ai été fait
l'écho médiatiquement aujourd'hui n'est
pas reconnu comme une personne
vulnérable l'étranger en situation
irrégulière qui est embauché
un bail un faux évidemment en tout cas
pas au sens légal du terme chez un
marchand de chez un marchand de sommeil
nous prévoyons ici évidemment la
pénalisation la délictualisation du
marchand de sommeil qui donne ses
logements et qui parfois pourrissent nos
communes à ces personnes extrêmement
vulnérables étrangères se sont
régulières devient donc une personne non
vulnérable qui ne permet de lutter
contre ceux qui souvent d'ailleurs dans
les enquêtes de police sont montrées
comme étant ceux qui tiennent parfois
l'emploi qui emploient ces personnes de
manière irrégulière mais aussi le
logement créant ainsi des normes réseau
d'immigration irrégulière qui au fil du
temps deviennent malheureusement des
personnes qu'on ne peut plus expulser
tant ils peuvent montrer qu'ils ont eu
leur vie privée et familiale dans notre
pays deuxième point après le contenu
après le continuum il y a les frontières
trois dispositions extrêmement fortes
pour le renforcement de nos frontières
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord les moyens donnés à la police
aux frontières désormais d'inspecter les
véhicules qui ne peuvent pas le faire
aux frontières c'est absurde et ces
temps-ci et donc ça c'est une
disposition qu'il a fait écho sans doute
à une décision monsieur président de la
commission des lois auquel vous êtes je
crois un peu ému celle du Conseil
constitutionnel sur les pouvoirs des
douaniers qui évidemment était nous
aider dans les contrôles aux frontières
nous proposons d'étendre ses pouvoirs
législatifs de contrôle et d'inspection
des véhicules à nos frontières par la
police aux frontières le deuxième sujet
là aussi qui parfois faisait polémique
mais qui pour la première fois a mis
dans un projet de loi c'est la
coercition pour prendre les empreintes
digitales des personnes qui ne veulent
pas être prises en empreinte on a
pénalisé dans une loi précédente le fait
que quelqu'un refusait de prendre ses
empreintes mais désormais nous proposons
dans un texte et pour la première fois
dans l'histoire d'un texte sur
l'immigration la coercition c'est à dire
que les policiers pourront obligés des
personnes ce qu'on appelle de pas
duchage à mettre leurs doigts évidemment
sur relevé
de ces de ces appareils et puis
troisième sujet nous avons négocié
précédemment dans les Conseils européens
un sujet très important qui s'appelle
Ethias c'est une donc traduction
législative de décision européenne pour
faire très vite nous allons mettre en
place l'entrée sortie Schengen dans
notre sur notre continent ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que désormais ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui tout
citoyen de l'espace Schengen et tout
étranger qui rentre dans l'espace
Schengen aura une fiche biométrique dans
l'ensemble des frontières aéroportuaires
portuaires frontières tout court dans
l'Europe ce qui nous permettra de suivre
l'intégralité des personnes qui sont de
votre sol ça fait écho à ce que je
disais en introduction de pouvoir
regarder bien sûr leur identité
connaître leur âge sans aucune
contestation possible grâce à leur
empreinte ne pas les confort avec des
faux documents et pouvoir évidemment
avoir une politique européenne de
contrôle et donc une fois qu'on a fait
l'entrée sortie Schengen 6 mois après
nous pouvons faire Ethias c'est quoi
Ethias c'est le fait que toutes les
polices et je gendarmerie européenne
pourront sur leur contrôle de téléphone
Neo vous savez ce que ce qu'on les
policiers gendarmes quand vous les voyez
dans la rue pour en faire des
vérifications identité de Schengen c'est
à dire que personne ne pourra plus
tricher sur son identité à partir du
moment où nous aurons mis en place ce
système Ethias il nous faut une
disposition législative pour mettre en
place évidemment Ethias pour nous est
important non seulement pour lutter
contre l'immigration irrégulière pour
pouvoir mieux expulser les personnes qui
ne sont pas régulières mais aussi dans
les lutte contre le terrorisme la
perspective des Jeux olympiques de Paris
enfin je terminerai sur la fin de la fin
de la double peine les dispositions de
l'article 9 et l'article 10 avec une
difficulté pour l'article 10 on y
reviendra peut-être puisque quand c'est
l'État a décidé de le disjoindre mais
nous avons décidé de le remettre dans le
texte pour que nous ayons ce débat ici
devant le Sénat c'est de dire qu'il ne
peut plus y avoir de protection pour les
personnes qui commettent des crimes
des dédiés extrêmement graves sur le sol
de la République donc ce qui relève de
10 ans de prison ou 5 ans en récidive
j'ai bien ce qui relève et pas ceux qui
est condamné on aura sans doute un long
débat sur ce sujet aujourd'hui 8
dispositions empêchent à l'intérieur
d'expulser ces personnes chacun se
rappelle que c'est dans les années 2000
que la fin la double peine a été mis en
place et qui n'a été copié par aucun
pays européen et qui n'est ni
conventionnel ni constitutionnel
d'ailleurs le Conseil d'État
l'ajustement relevé si vous étiez marié
avec la française ou une Française si
vous aviez des enfants en France bref si
vous étiez arrivé en France avant l'âge
de 13 ans et vous commettiez les actes
après l'âge de 18 ans il y avait un
certain nombre de protection qui était
prévu par la loi le miniso intérieur
quand même vous auriez commis des crimes
ignobles ne pouvait pas vous expulser
parce que la vie privée est familiale
était ainsi sauvegardée si j'ose dire à
binicio nous proposons que nous fassions
tomber l'intégralité de ces protections
subsidiaires de ces protections d'ordre
public et désormais nous ne regardons
pas la situation de la personne selon sa
vie privée familiale mais qu'en gagnant
le crime que la Comic nous puissions
expulser ainsi ces personnes bien sûr
elle pourra toujours avoir recours
devant le juge qui pourra considérer que
la décision de l'administrative est
exagérée mais je constate que on fait
souvent se dire au juge des choses qui
ne dit pas vous savez que ce disposition
n'est pas valable pour les actes
qualifient de terrorisme de séparatistes
et le Conseil d'État parfois on l'a vu
dans l'affaire ecuissen donne raison au
ministère de l'Intérieur et la vie
privée familiale alors que cette
personne par exemple avait eu quatre
enfants nés en France qui s'étaient
mariés en France que ça faisait que
lui-même était né en France a quand même
considéré évidemment que l'État avait
raison de se défendre contre ce sinistre
personnage et donc à autorisé son
expulsion la fin de la fin de la double
peine c'est évidemment une disposition
extrêmement forte pour lutter contre les
étrangers auteurs d'actes de vacances
extrêmement graves on pense au crime on
pense bien évidemment aux attentes aux
policiers et aux gendarmes aux attentes
aux élus aux conjugales et au trafic de
drogue demain ces personnes malgré leur
statut personnels ne pourront pas
revendiquer la protection de la vie
privée et familiale devant le ministère
de l'Intérieur pour connaître leur
expulsion ce qui sera une bonne chose
voilà monsieur le Président en quelques
mots la présentation très succincte trop
succin les articles qui relèvent
directement de ma compétence merci
Monsieur de la parole tout de suite
monsieur du travail monsieur Duchamp
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Miss chergérald madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à mon tour en quelques mots de
revenir sur les dispositions du projet
de loi que nous vous présentons avec
Gérald Darmanin pour ce qui concerne le
travail et en particulier l'intégration
par le travail et par la langue le les
dispositions nous vous présentons
s'appuient en réalité sur un constat et
une conviction le constat est que le
marché du travail tel que nous le
connaissons en France ne propose pas une
situation professionnelle satisfaisante
aux étrangers qui sont présents sur
notre territoire les chiffres le
montrent l'illustre depuis maintenant
longtemps
quel que soit le contexte économique en
cas de récession comme en cas de
croissance comme en cas de reprise le
taux de chômage des personnes nées à
l'étranger et en moyenne presque deux
fois supérieure au taux de chômage des
personnes nées en France même dans une
période de création d'emplois
importantes comme celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et de tension de
recrutement le squelette taux de chômage
est à 7,2 % pour le taux de chômage
général et la population générale il est
à 13% pour les personnes qui sont nées à
l'étranger donc présentes comme immigré
sur notre territoire c'est d'autant plus
frappant que nous avons un système qui
est d'une part ne permet pas
d'accompagner suffisamment vers l'emploi
les étrangers en situation régulière sur
notre territoire et qui dans le même
temps maintient dans les régularités
maintient dans l'inégalité des hommes et
des femmes qui depuis longtemps sont
présents sur le territoire et
travaillent très souvent de manière
régulière mais j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir cela aboutit à des situations
souvent inextriables avec des
entreprises qui comptent sur un certain
nombre de salariés alors que leur
présence sur le territoire était
régulière
gens bien même leur emploi et lui
déclarait et tout à fait régulier et des
situations qui lorsque la justice en est
saisie amène à cette situation
inextricable présentée par le ministre
de l'intérieur ou l'expulsion et
prononcée mais en réalité elle n'est pas
possible pour des éléments relatifs à la
vie privée familiale et un ancienneté de
l'installation sur le territoire donc
nous pensons que les principes de
justice et les principes d'efficacité
demandent et comment si je puis dire
d'apporter une réponse à cette
difficulté la conviction après le
constat c'est que l'intégration et la
bonne intégration la meilleure
intégration passe à la fois par le
travail et par la langue par le travail
parce que c'est évidemment un facteur
d'autonomie d'émancipation et d'accès à
la capacité à des individus de
construire et finalement de vivre sur le
territoire de la manière la plus
autonome possible et la langue pour
cette capacité évidemment à s'intégrer à
parler à partager et à communiquer avec
toutes celles et ceux qui nous entourent
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons avec ce texte proposer des
mesures qui permettent d'abord de
favoriser l'intégration par le travail
de favoriser l'apprentissage de la
langue et d'en faire une des
motivations en tout cas un
obligation pour réussir c'est parcours
d'intégration c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle nous voulons que celles et ceux
qui se prêtent délibérément au
recrutement de personnes en situation
irrégulière puisse être plus durement
plus durement sanctionné pour ce qui
concerne l'intégration par le travail
nous proposons donc de créer un nouveau
type de séjour temporaire relatif aux
métiers en tension avec une volonté qui
est que ce type de séjour tel que prévu
à l'article 3 puis s'adresser à des
salariés des secteurs les plus
intensions en termes d'emploi pour
faciliter l'intégration de ces
travailleurs étrangers qui contribuent
déjà le plus activement à soulager les
tensions de recrutement et qui
travaillent sur notre territoire il ne
s'agit pas d'un titre de séjour pensé
pour susciter la venue sur le territoire
d'étrangers non-communautaire les gens
si d'ailleurs sur le caractère non
communautaire puisque dès lors qu'on
parle d'étrangers communautaire la
liberté de circulation fait qu'ils ne
sont pas concernés par les dispositions
que vous présentons il s'agit d'un titre
qui permet de régulariser la situation
d'hommes et de femmes qui sont présents
sur notre territoire depuis longtemps et
qui travaillent très souvent d'ailleurs
d'hommes et de femmes qui travaillent
parce que au moment où ils ont signé un
contrat de travail ils étaient en
situation régulière et que leur titre de
séjour n'a pas été renouvelés pour une
raison pour une autre et nous traduisons
cette intention de régulariser
uniquement des personnes sur notre
territoire qui travaille et qui d'une
certaine manière disent leur volonté
d'intégration participe à leur
intégration par le travail en précisant
dans le projet de loi que nous vous
présentons que cette éligibilité à ce
nouveau type de séjour sera conditionné
par une présence sur le territoire
depuis au moins trois ans et le fait
d'avoir travaillé au moins 8 mois au
cours des 24 derniers mois et donc nous
sommes véritablement dans une logique de
critères pour faire en sorte que ces
travailleurs ne restent pas sans droit
ni au séjour ni au travail et puisse
ainsi voir leur situation régularisée
afin que là aussi la sécurité juridique
temporeux que pour leur employeur pour
définir les secteurs en tension nous
souhaitons nous appuyer sur la liste des
métiers en tension qui existent déjà qui
répertorie dans l'état du droit les
métiers où il est possible de recruter
de la main d'oeuvre étrangère non
communautaire sans eau sans opposabilité
de l'administration aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on employeur souhaite recruter un
salarié non étranger non communautaire
il est tenu de demander préalablement la
signature du contrat de travail une
autorisation administrative de signer ce
contrat de travail qui conditionne
d'ailleurs l'accès à un visa ou
l'autorisation d'entrer sur le
territoire la liste des métiers en
tension telle qu'elle existe telle
qu'elle a été réactualisée il est encore
quelques années permet aux employeurs
qui recrutent des étrangers non
communautaires de s'affranchir de cette
autorisation administrative dès lors
qu'il recrute sur un poste répertorié
comme étant particulièrement attention
nous souhaitons donc utiliser cette
liste pour permettre d'intégrer plus
rapidement des travailleurs étrangers
déjà sur le territoire et non pas en
recrutement et qui exerce donc dans ces
métiers les plus intensions cette liste
doit être révisée de nombreuses
organisations professionnelles nous ont
dit notamment dans le secteur de la
restauration dans le secteur de
l'entretien des bâtiments et des locaux
l'inadéquation entre la liste et la
situation du marché du travail tel que
nous la connaissons aujourd'hui il y a
par exemple dans les secteurs de la
restauration le métier de comic-cuisine
qui n'apparaît pas dans la liste comme
étant en tension de la même manière que
les agents d'entretien des bâtiments
hommes et femmes de ménage
n'apparaissent pas dans la liste des
métiers en tension alors que nous savons
que la part des étrangers non
communautaires a exercé dans ces métiers
particulièrement importantes cette liste
doit faire donc l'objet d'une révision
cette révision est encadrée par un
certain nombre de critères notamment
statistiques et prend une dimension
régionale puisque la liste est souvent
présentée comme une liste nationale et
en réalité elle connaît des déclinaisons
régionales pour être la plus adaptée
possible aux besoins de l'économie à
l'échelle de territoire régionaux qui
d'après la jurisprudence sont
suffisamment larges pour éviter de créer
des phénomènes de discrimination si des
territoires plus étroits plus réduits
étaient retenus
cette procédure que nous voulons créer
vient en réalité après une première
expérience que nous connaissons celle de
la circulaire dites valse qui prévoit
des admissions exceptionnelles au séjour
admission exceptionnelle au séjour qui
pour une part importante sont des
admissions motivées par des motifs
familiaux sociaux privés et pour une
part moins importante et même
minoritaire pour des motifs économiques
bonhomme si vous me permettez cette
expression ce sont à peu près 7000
admissions exceptionnelles au séjour qui
sont prononcés au titre de la circulaire
Valls pour des motifs professionnels ou
économiques et nous pensons même s'il
est toujours difficile de prévoir le
rythme auquel des régularisations de
situations déjà existantes pourraient
intervenir que certainement un chiffre
autour duquel nous pourrions aboutir
dans le cadre de la mise en oeuvre de
cet article 3 cette circulaire valse
présente deux difficultés d'abord une
application hétérogène sur le territoire
puisque renvoyer à une forme de pouvoir
discrétionnaire des autorités
préfectorales et une autre difficulté
qui implique que l'employeur
se déclare et accompagne la
régularisation il y a deux limites qui
sont créées par cette obligation de
participation de l'employeur la première
est qu'il existe légitimement les
employeurs qui craignent cette
exposition puisqu'ils doivent dire à un
moment que tel ou tel de leur salarié
est en situation irrégulière sur le
territoire et ce n'est pas forcément une
démarche facile il y a une autre limite
qui heureusement plus minoritaire mais
qui est beaucoup plus grande qui
consiste à ce que des employeurs le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui est qualifie
tout à l'heure à raison l'employeur
voyou trouve tout à fait confortable et
tout à fait positif pour eux de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur des salariés en situation
irrégulière parce que ça crée un rapport
de dépendance et évidemment cela change
le lien du contrat tel que défini par le
contrat de travail nous souhaitons donc
avec ce nouveau titre les étrangers en
situation irrégulière mais exerçant une
activité depuis plusieurs mois et étant
présent sur le territoire depuis
plusieurs années activité régulière
puisse solliciter eux-mêmes leur
régularisation
évidemment si nous nous contentions de
créer un titre de un an renouvelable au
même condition nous ne ferions que
repousser le problème d'une certaine
manière et nous prévoyons que les
étrangers concernaient puissent par
exemple si ils sont signataires d'un CDI
à terme demandés l'accès à une carte de
séjour plus réelle mais dans ce cas-là
cet accès à une carte de séjour plus
réelle serait soumis au même critères
que ceux exposés par le ministre de
l'Intérieur notamment en matière de
maîtrise de la langue ou d'engagement
sur les valeurs républicaines je sais
que cette disposition suicide des
interrogations elle suscite des attentes
notamment dans les secteurs économiques
les plus concernés les fédérations
professionnelles les plus concernées
mais comme elle suit des interrogations
il nous paraît important à la fois dans
des battre mais aussi de prévoir que le
Parlement puisse après une première
période de mise en oeuvre de cette
réforme
évaluer son effet et décider ou non de
sa conduction c'est la raison pour
laquelle le texte ne vous que nous vous
présentons prévoit une clause de
revoyure au 31 décembre 2026 donc sur la
base de cette évaluation le Parlement
puisse décider si cette nouveauté de
séjour doit être pérennisée ou non
lorsqu'on souhaite finalement sécuriser
la présence des travailleurs sur le
territoire cela implique un corollaire
qui est d'empêcher que de telles
situations puissent se reproduire et en
particulier le situation sont tout à
fait délibérées je pense aux employeurs
qui délibérément on recourt à des
personnes en situation irrégulière à la
fois pour des activités professionnelles
régulières et parfois pour des activités
professionnelles non régulières
lorsqu'il y a des activités non
professionnel non régulière et exercées
par des situations en Suède des
personnes en situation irrégulière ça
mérite évidemment les sanctions les plus
fortes et c'est la raison pour laquelle
maintenant bien évidemment les sanctions
pénales telles qu'elles sont prévues et
qui viennent sanctionner les situations
les plus graves et les délaiss les plus
graves nous souhaitons cependant que les
employeurs qui délibérément recrutent
des personnes en situation irrégulière
même si c'est pour exercer une activité
régulière puis cette sanctionner plus
rapidement les procédures pénales que
j'ai évoquées sont une sortie de
sanction lourde mais elles sont longues
et donc nous souhaitons pouvoir créer
une amende administrative à la main des
autorités administratives et donc
préfectorales pour sanctionner à hauteur
de 4000 euros par salarié étrangers
employés légalement les employeurs qui
délibérément on recourt à de la main
d'oeuvre en situation irrégulière
l'avantage d'une sanction administrative
c'est sa rapidité et la possibilité
d'infliger une sanction dans un moment
suffisamment rapproché du moment où
l'infraction est constatée alors que les
sanctions pénales qui sont plus lourdes
bien évidemment avec beaucoup plus de
temps nous souhaitons aussi le ministre
de l'Intérieur a dit empêcher la
création en tout cas l'apparition de
situation dans lesquelles des personnes
en situation irrégulière sur le
territoire crée eux-mêmes une activité
économique une activité professionnelle
de manière régulière je pense à la
création d'entreprises individuelle
l'accès aux statut d'entreprise
individuelle comme l'accès aux statut
d'auto-entrepreneur aujourd'hui nous
devons renforcer les conditions pour
accéder à ce statut d'entreprise
individuelle ou d'auto-entrepreneurs et
nous prévoyons dans l'article 5 de
conditionner cet accès aux personnes en
situation régulière sur le territoire et
donc d'obliger la présentation d'un
titre de séjour régulier sur le
territoire pour pouvoir ainsi créer une
entreprise individuelle ou accéder au
statut d'auto-entrepreneur aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le cas ça n'est pas
suffisamment encadré et c'est ainsi que
très régulièrement les plateformes
puisque nous renvoyons souvent au
travail de plateforme en la matière son
contrainte de déconnecter un certain
nombre de profils dès lors qu'elle
constate que celui ou celle qui est
derrière le profil d'auto-entrepreneur
est en réalité en situation irrégulière
il y a un certain nombre d'autres
mesures que nous vous proposons de
prendre pour faciliter l'intégration par
le travail et lever un certain nombre de
contraintes je pense notamment à
l'article 4 qui a comme objectif de
faciliter l'accès au travail d'un
certain nombre d'une partie des
demandeurs d'asile je m'explique en un
mot lorsque vous êtes demandeur d'asile
vous n'avez pas le droit d'exercer une
activité professionnelle sauf au bout de
six mois ou après six mois bah c'est sur
le territoire si la demande d'asile n'a
pas été construite de manière définitive
vous pouvez solliciter une dérogation et
obtenir le droit de travail et ensuite
si vous êtes reconnu et si votre demande
d'asile aboutit vous avez évidemment le
droit au travail nous proposons que
chaque année un arrêté du ministre de
l'Intérieur puisse déterminer la liste
des pays pour lesquels les taux
d'admission sont les plus élevés et
permettent pour ces seuls pays la
possibilité de travailler pour les
demandeurs d'asile le fait de renvoyer
cette définition liste un arrêté elle
mérite de la souplesse tout à l'heure le
ministre de l'Intérieur l'a dit la liste
des pays pour lesquels les taux
d'acceptation des demandes d'asile sur
les plus élevés est une liste qui varie
extrêmement vite au gré des évolutions
géopolitiques et donc il faut pouvoir
modifier cette liste aussi rapidement
que varie les taux d'admission de
manière à être efficace et ne pas créer
un flux que nous ne serions maîtrisé
la deuxième chose que nous voulons faire
en termes de levée de contraintes ne
concerne pas des personnes présentes sur
le territoire mais des personnes qui
aujourd'hui souhaitent venir travailler
en France dans le cadre de ce que nous
appelons le passeport talent nous
souhaitons modifier le passeport talent
qui existe aujourd'hui qui est organisé
en 11 catégories en regroupant les
catégories pour lui donner plus de
lisibilité parler de cartes de séjour
talons et permettre la venue sur le
territoire de personnes extrêmement
compétentes formées avec des projets
d'investissement et qui répondent à des
besoins de notre économie et des besoins
en termes d'attractivité et nous
souhaitons par ailleurs créer une carte
spécifique pour les talents dans le
domaine des professions médicales
notamment les médecins les pharmaciens
les chirurgiens dentistes avec des
procédures d'admission particulière des
délais particuliers mais aussi bien
évidemment la vérification de toutes les
équivalences pour permettre de garantir
la qualité des soins je termine par un
point sur la question de l'intégration
par l'apprentissage de la langue nous
grandi et le ministre de l'Intérieur l'a
dit aussi nous souhaitons relever les
niveaux d'exigence en termes
linguistique pour obtenir une carte de
séjour plus réelle un instant de ce qui
existe pour obtenir une carte de
résidence c'est une nouvelle exigence
qui est fixée à l'article 1 de même
qu'il est prévu à l'article 2 que nous
permettions que nous puissions permettre
aux travailleurs étrangers qui demandent
la possibilité d'obtenir une carte de
séjour plus réelle de se former aux
Français c'est la raison pour laquelle
en plus des dispositions d'insertion
d'intégration de formation français tels
que prévu par la loopnie et qui ont été
évoqués dans le propos de Gérald
Darmanin nous prévoyons cet article 2
autorise le gouvernement à prendre un
décret après une constatation
interprofessionnelle pour dire quel
nombre d'heures de formation français
pour être effectué sur le plan de
travail en réalité ce à quoi nous
voulons apporter une réponse c'est la
situation d'hommes et de femmes qui
travaillent souvent dans des secteurs en
tension et avec des rythmes des horaires
parfois compliqué dans le domaine de
restauration dans le domaine de
l'entretien et pour qui il est
extrêmement compliqué de cumuler sur la
même journée sur la même semaine à la
fois leur activité professionnelle avec
le fait d'assister au cours nécessaire
de français pour obtenir le niveau
demandé désormais qui sera demandé
désormais pour obtenir une carte de
séjour plus réelle et donc prévoyons
qu'il puisse ainsi se voir libérer du
temps pour participer à ces formations
et ainsi satisfaire à cette nouvelle
obligation et cette nouvelle exigence
que nous donnons voilà monsieur le
Président les différents points qui
concernent l'intégration par le travail
et par la langue que contient ce projet
de loi
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
Monsieur les ministres je vais
maintenant donner la parole à nos
rapporteurs puis ensuite d'autres
collègues sont déjà inscrits pour des
prises de parole madame Jorda merci
monsieur le Président nous allons
peut-être poser nos questions
en une seule fois si je puis dire je
suis bonne Carrère et moi-même ce qui
permettra à Monsieur et ministre de nous
répondre première question qui a trait
aux articles 1 et 2 donc qui s'adresse à
vous monsieur Dussac sur le niveau de
langue dont vous indiquez que vous avez
rehaussé le niveau d'exigence il faut
dire qu'il n'y en avait pas pour
l'instant si ce n'est le fait d'assister
à la formation aujourd'hui vous prévoyez
qu'un niveau de langue doit être atteint
pour pouvoir se voir délivrer une carte
de séjour plurielle mais vous n'indiquez
jamais dans la loi quel est le niveau de
langue alors je sais que il peut nous
être répondu que c'est réglementaire
nous nous estimons que c'est législatif
et c'est toujours assez difficile mais
c'est souvent le cas dans ce texte de
prendre une décision sans savoir
véritablement
la demande qui va être qui va être
formulée donc pouvez-vous nous dire quel
est le niveau de langue qui est
envisagée dans le cas de l'étude
d'impact vous aviez indiqué que il était
déjà envisagé de rehausser le niveau de
langue pour l'acquisition de la
nationalité française il n'en a rien été
pour l'instant quand est-il exactement
de ce projet donc quel va être le niveau
de langue qui va être exigé
par ailleurs vous l'avez indiqué à
l'instant dans l'article 2 les
employeurs sont mis à contribution pour
pouvoir permettre à l'étranger qui
travaille d'acquérir ce niveau de langue
par des mesures de contraintes qui sont
beaucoup plus fortes que dans la
formation professionnelle habituelle que
répondez-vous à ceux qui disent que ça
n'est pas aux employeurs de faire les
frais en quelque sorte de la politique
migratoire de la France
merci
Philippe bonnecarère
votre question était posée alors je vais
aller vers monsieur Darmanin pour faire
et puis après je reviendrai monsieur
Duchamp bien sûr sur avec l'article 3 il
sans doute une question monsieur
Darmanin sur la réforme du contentieux
des étrangers
vous avez avec habilité
traditionnel fait référence au travail
Stal et au rapport de notre Président
Monsieur buffet
pourtant la proposition
législative que vous nous faites
sur ce sujet ne correspond pas à la
proposition
stable buffet la proposition stade
buffet c'était
un critère d'urgence on est sur une
procédure d'urgence chers tribunal
administratif du juge très rapidement
on est sur une procédure normale tu as
un délai plus classique pour apprécier
pour un peintre mis en tension
ce n'est pas exactement ce que vous avez
souhaité faire j'ai toujours une
procédure normale j'ai toujours deux
procédures d'urgence une procédure que
j'appellerai avec assignation résidence
et l'autre placement ancra vous avez des
niveaux de de délai qui sont un petit
peu différents mais je ne sais pas je
vais pas rentrer dans trop de détails et
vous créez une nouvelle procédure qui
manifestement dans votre esprit à
vocation être à la procédure majoritaire
ou
vous dites à un étranger mon cher
Monsieur ou ma chère Madame
je
vous demande de quitter le territoire
immédiatement
il n'y a pas de délai et donc dans ce
cadre vous demandez au Tribunal
Administratif de juger dans le cadre
d'un délit rapide mais vous n'avez pris
ni mesure des signations résidence ni
mesure de placement serein ce qui nous
laisse à penser que vous allez mettre en
tension les tribunaux administratifs
pour des situations qui ont en réalité
peu de chance de conduire à une Éloi à
une éloignement ou un éloignement rapide
puisque ce sont par définition des
situations où je n'ai ni assignation
résidence ni éloignement donc ma
question est la suivante pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas purement et simplement
suivi les préconisations Stales buffet
ou buffet Stal et pourquoi vous créez
cette procédure intermédiaire dont on
voit bien l'intérêt dans votre esprit
d'accélérer la procédure mais vous accès
de vous demander au tribunal
administratif d'aller vite pour régler
des situations dans tous les Français
qu'elles ne feront pas l'objet d'un
éloignement rapide il nous semble y
avoir une contradiction vous comprenez à
travers mes propos que nous avons un
faible pour la proposition Staël buffet
mais nous en écoutant volontiers votre
argumentation pour ne pas l'avoir suivi
encore une question même Jourda par le
ministre
et à Monsieur bonne Carrère non on
prenait au global et puis on fera une
réponse on va si vous voulez bien on va
poser peut-être parce qu'après les
questions des rapporteurs et ensuite
voilà nous nous tirons pour un moment
une question qui s'adresse sans doute à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
avez indiqué tout à l'heure que dans les
articles et 10 pour les résumer sans
entrer dans le détail technique il
s'agissait de lever les protections qui
aujourd'hui s'appliquait à des étrangers
qui ont commis des faits qui troublent
l'ordre public pour prendre un terme
très générique même si ce n'est pas
exactement ce qui est écrit mais c'est
le sens général si
nous combinons ces dispositions avec
l'instruction du 3 août dernier par
laquelle vous indiquez à vos services
que vous souhaitez que soit placé en
centre de rétention administrative donc
ensuite éloigné ou expulsé des personnes
qui sont effectivement celles qui
causent le plus de troubles à l'ordre
public ça dessine un paysage qui n'est
pas très clairement indiqué dans le
texte mais qui je crois ressort de du
travail d'audition notamment que nous
avons pu faire qui est que aujourd'hui
on va prioriser l'expulsion
l'éloignement des personnes qui sont
celles
l'ordre public en France que
faisons-nous des autres c'est à dire
celles qui sont en situation irrégulière
et qui font obser l'objet de décision
d'éloignement
et dans la droite ligne de cette
question l'article 12 prévoit que on ne
pourra plus passer en centre de
rétention administrative les mineurs de
16 ans
comment assurer l'éloignement des
familles si on ne peut plus passer
ensemble de restant sur administrative
les mineurs et pourquoi cette restreint
au centre de rétention administrative et
pas aux locaux de restauration
administrative ou aux zones d'attente
qui sont aussi des lieux où on retient
des mineurs
merci Monsieur bonne Carrère deux
questions également
réparties quittablement une pour
Monsieur dussoft une pour Monsieur
dahmana pour Monsieur Darmanin je
souhaiterais monsieur mise à l'intérieur
vous interrogez sur la pertinence ou pas
de venir vous aider sur la question des
laisser passer consulaires et notre idée
serait de raisonner quant au fait que
l'immigration n'est pas un sujet de la
France mais un sujet de la France et des
pays sources et le Sénat avait vu
monsieur le ministre avec une certaine
satisfaction
notre pays menait une politique de
réduction des visas en disant en termes
de réciprocité au pays concernés cher
ami soyez un petit peu plus attentif aux
demandes de laisser passer
consulaire que vous ne le faites
actuellement nous avons vu que cette
politique de réduction du nombre de visa
avait été abandonnés nous n'avons pas
constaté cependant dans nos visites dans
les préfectures une grande amélioration
de l'obtention de laisser passer
consulaire peut être très très à la
marche concernant l’algérie mais c'est
vraiment à la marge et dont nous nous
posons la question de savoir si nous
vous rendrions services si nous avions
l'idée d'un amendement qui quelque part
conduirait le Parlement a donné une
orientation on pourrait même être
quelquefois un peu plus prescriptif
quand au nombre de visa quand au nombre
de types de séjour qui pourrait être
autorisés chaque année dans notre pays
et donc en d'autres termes est-ce que
une telle position du Parlement
définissant un chiffre annuel vous
rendrez service dans la négociation
amicale mettons on imagine qu'il y a
aussi une part de rapport de force assez
importante ce sera pour de force qu'on
aimerait vous aider à créer à travers un
tel système
monsieur dussobe vous vous doutez qu'on
ne peut pas échapper monsieur ministre
pardon excusez-moi ma femme la
familiarité de mon papa monsieur le
ministre
on ne peut pas échapper à l'article 3 et
nous avons un peu de mal à comprendre où
vous voulez aller si vous voulez aller à
une régularisation de la situation de
gens qui travaillent dans notre pays qui
sont là depuis assez longtemps et qui
sont placés dans une situation
d'illégalité ou de clandestinité on peut
comprendre votre souhait de voir la
société française regardez les réalités
en face et
régulariser si tel est le cas
quel est l'intérêt des
mesures
successives de sanctions que vous
proposez aux employeurs puisque vous
dites un employeur si on régularise ton
salarié qui est donc en une situation
d'illégalité etc on te garantit un
contrôle et tu auras une sanction pénale
peut-être probablement tu auras une
amende aussi on rajoute une amende
administrative et on va lui épargner
éventuellement la fermeture
administrative on voit bien qu'il y a
une contradiction dans le texte entre
votre souhait de régularisation et les
différentes fonctions subtiles en
d'autres termes si il doit y avoir
régularisation il faut à ce moment-là
l'assumer avec une amnistie à l'égard de
l'employeur du style mon cher employeur
Vous régularisez vous offrez un contrat
durant indéterminé à votre salarié à des
conditions normales et il n'y a pas de
sanction il y a pas de sanction pénale
qui est une manière de vous dire et de
dire aussi à mes collègues en l'état
actuel du texte nous ne pensons pas
qu'il y aura énormément de demandes
d'application de cet article 3 si par
contre je ne suis pas convaincu par
cette idée directrice que la
régularisation d'une bonne chose et si
je pense deux choses
si je pense que vous faites courir un
risque à notre pays en termes d'appel
d'air aussi je pense que vous faites
courir un autre risque au pays en termes
de trappe à bas salaire je vais vous
demander d'aller un petit peu plus loin
si je pense que il y a un risque d'appel
d'air je peux le combler en vous disant
mais on va limiter le nombre
annuellement on a dit il y en aura
encore une fois pas énormément il y a
donc pas de difficultés à fixer un
objectif il n'y a pas de problème
d'inconstitutionnalité on est en matière
professionnelle donc je peux traiter par
le nombre que pensez-vous d'une telle
hypothèse je peux également traité par
la réduction du délai parce qu'il y a
quand même une curiosité dans l'état
actuel de l'article 3 c'est que vous
proposez jusqu'au 31 décembre 2026 alors
que nous parlons d'une régularisation si
vous permettez la formule de stock si je
fais une régularisation je la fais à un
moment donné là si j'étais malicieux ce
que je ne suis pas monsieur le ministre
et si j'étais pasteur je pourrais
interpréter la disposition vous avez
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2026 je ferai mon
petit calcul le texte me donne la
possibilité de demander ma régulariser
sur bout de trois ans si je me dépêche
de faire venir mes excellents clients de
tel ou tel pays d'ici le 31 décembre
2023 2024 2025-2026 il se rendent dans
les temps pour demander la pour demander
le temps la régularisation je me pose
donc la question de comment
voudrais vous pousser un peu dans votre
tranchement pour nous dire comment
éviter ce risque d'appel d'air et si je
crains ce qui serait plutôt mon analyse
monsieur Medis pour tout vous dire si je
crains la trappe à bas salaire j'ai deux
sujets
qui nous mettent vraiment mal à l'aise
sur la rédaction article de l'article 3
le
fond du sujet c'est que vous demandez à
traiter une question économique celle
des métiers en tension
par une disposition régalienne si
l'année qui est un texte en matière
d'immigration traité de l'économie par
un texte régalien
ça va pas très bien ensemble et donc on
voit bien qu'il nous manque une
articulation
par rapport à la négociation collective
si demain on veut que nos concitoyens
aillent vers des emplois qui n'ont pas
trop pas envie d'occuper actuellement et
qui est moins d'étrangers pour l'occuper
on voit bien qu'il y a des problèmes de
formation on voit bien qu'il y a des
problèmes de rémunération donc si dans
cet article 3 on avait un lien avec la
négociation collective et avec donc la
responsabilité conjointe entre les
employeurs les salariés et la société
j'avoue que je serai plus à l'aise et
dernier élément et j'arrête dans
l'exercice en honte à vous challenger si
vous me permettez cette formule sur cet
article 3 c'est encore plus bizarre pour
des gens qui comme moi craignent un peu
cette trappe à mes salaires que vous
créez un nouveau type de séjour bon ça
c'est encore un autre sujet mais vous
créez un titre de séjour métier en
tension qui va être opposable
c'est-à-dire que si je suis en situation
irrégularité
je vais et j'estime pouvoir bénéficier
des dispositions de l'article 3 je vais
pouvoir s'agissant d'une disposition de
pain droit je vais pouvoir saisir le
juge administratif de ma demande de
régularisation et on va faire du juge
administratif là où c'était le préfet
avec les circulaires Valls on va dans
une situation où le juge administratif
va devenir le juge de cette régulation
économique vous m'accorderez qu'il est
pas vraiment quand même
outillé pour cet élément donc que je
regarde l'article 3 en résumé
excusez-moi d'avoir été un petit peu
long mais c'est encore une fois pour
vous pousser un peu dans votre
retranchement si je suis favorable à la
régularisation je n'ai pas satisfaction
dans l'article 3 si je crains l'appel
d'air je suis pas plus satisfait si je
crains la trappe à basse à l'air je n'ai
pas ma réponse dans l'actualité donc
c'est un une disposition qui me paraît
perfectible et auriez-vous des
propositions pour tenir compte de ces
différents points de vue dont je peux
imaginer que vous les retrouverez un
moment donné dans les débats devant le
Sénat merci merci monsieur laporteur je
venais la parole au ministre je voudrais
indiquer à tout le monde que on a encore
à peu près une heure d'horloge il y a
déjà cinq collègues qui sont inscrits
pour prendre la parole sont toutes
d'autres donc voilà c'est pour vous dire
à peu près du temps dont nous disposons
bien monsieur Darmanin la concision
monsieur le Président je vais essayer
d'être concis mais répondre évidemment
aux interrogations de nos rapporteurs
peut-être avec l'autorisation
administrée du sol sur la première
partie de la première question de Madame
Jourda sur le niveau de langue
moi je n'ai rien contre le fait que ce
soit législatif donc qui peut plus peut
le mot on verra ce que dira le Conseil
constitutionnel mais en tout cas vous ne
trouverez pas de points de bloquant de
la part du gouvernement donc je n'ai
rien au fait que ce soit maître
effectivement dans la loi moi je
pencherai pour le niveau de l'angle plus
important la 2 madame la sénatrice à
condition que nous conditionnons un A2
orale parce que je pense que ce serait
pour le coup très demandé aux étrangers
qui arrivent sur d'autres sols de
pouvoir écrire à la 2 en français je
pense que il est pas tout à fait certain
d'ailleurs que l'ensemble des personnes
qui
choisir ont déjà des titres de séjour où
sont eux-mêmes Français sachent
parfaitement répondre à cette
interrogation de la 2 à l'écrit mais la
deux à l'oral je pense que c'est un
niveau d'exigence quand même important
voir très voir très important je suis
pas là pour rentrer dans le débat entre
les LR monsieur le sénateur de Brest
la question du A2 à l'oral moi je pense
que c'est à dire l'exigence importante
qui veut donc aussi dire que les moyens
de l'État doivent être mobilisés pour
permettre aux gens de passer cet examen
mais encore une fois je n'ai rien contre
le fait que vous proposiez par principe
le fait qu'il puisse être législatif sur
la simulation elle parallèle que vous
avez fait madame Astrid je pense qu'il
est pas tout à fait juste si je peux me
permettre certes dans l'assimilation il
y a aussi la langue pour devenir
français mais il y a beaucoup d'examens
il y a un exemple plus complet sur les
valeurs de la République le commandement
pas à l'étranger qui aurait une carte
sur annuelle par exemple vous savez
qu'on demande aujourd'hui qui est Jeanne
d'Arc qui est Napoléon cité 5 ministres
du gouvernement pas sûr que tous les
Français sachent absolument répondre à
la question des ministres de Brest et
par ailleurs citer trois plats français
bon donc les entretiens d'affiliation se
repose sur d'autres choses que sur que
sur la que sur la langue
bien sûr mais je comprends votre votre
demande et je n'y vois pas
d'inconvénient sur le deuxième point sur
la procédure évoquée par Monsieur bonne
carrière moi je partage pas votre
opinion et sauf à évidemment
et sans vexé le président buffet bien
sûr bien sûr le président buffet dans et
la commission ainsi que ce qui avait
évoqué repris par le président la serre
c'était on passe de 12 procédures à
trois et en gros votre question revient
à dire pourquoi fait de 12 à 4 si j'ai
bien compris votre votre demande bon
nous on crée une quatrième procédure
justement pour je fais le lien avec
Madame la question suivante pour l'ordre
public et on dit que justement il faut
réduire pour un certain nombre de cas
qui me paraisse pas contre moi ce que
vous dites majoritaire monsieur sénateur
mais on doit pouvoir réduire le délai de
présence sur sa nationale de ces
personnes qui ont un député pour
appliquer cette itef parce que justement
nous avons laissé passer consulaire
d'ailleurs vous constater que le projet
du gouvernement c'était 48 heures et
après discussion avec le Conseil d'État
qui n'a pas trouvé que notre quatrième
procédure était était inimaginable dans
le droit nous a dit plutôt 72 heures et
nous pensons au contraire que nous
allons fluidifier cette partie
particulière des étrangers que qui qui
doit être expulsé parce qu'il propose
une menace à l'ordre public particulière
et que un certain nombre de personnes ne
passe pas par le crâne passe pas par le
L1 ne passe pas par la signature
résidence expulser les fort heureusement
nous arrivons à expulser un certain
nombre d'étrangers avec certains types
de nationalités dans certains cas bien
sûr c'est pas le cas général si j'ose
dire directement une fois que le qtf a
été a été notifié et aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup d'étrangers qui soient ne font
pas le recours et donc vous aurez
compris aussi que l'implicite c'était la
réduction du délai c'était pour éviter
évidemment d'avoir trop laps de temps de
recours qui nous permet malheureusement
de ne pas pouvoir expulser les personnes
il y a aussi ça dans la non exécution
des audit F mais aussi d'être pour bien
signaler au tribunaux administratif que
notre demande est express par définition
et qu'elle est et qu'elle est
prioritaire la difficulté d'aujourd'hui
mais je pense que chacun ça le constate
c'est que le tribunal administratif le
juge administratif il sait plus très
bien ce qui relève du priorité et pas du
prioritaire dans la base du contentieux
qui lui arrive donc on a essayé de du
classifier ce qui du point de vue de
l'intérêt public au nom du gouvernement
et du législateur si vous l'adopter
relève de la priorité et donc moi je
tiens à mon quatrième ma quatrième
procédure
l'occasion d'en reparler je voudrais
dire ici et sortirai évidemment les les
compétences législateur que vous êtes
que ça a été le fruit d'un très long
travail de discussion avec le Conseil
d'État parce que dans ce texte
particulier chacun concentre le Conseil
d'État est à la fois bien sûr le juge du
droit peut-être que de le proposons mais
aussi un peu intéressé à la faire voilà
certains pourraient dire d'ailleurs qui
qui se jugent lui-même en jugeant le
texte que nous proposons c'est pour ça
que j'étais pas tout à fait d'accord
avec le fait que un certain nombre de
disposition comme la territorisation de
la CNDA ne méritait pas d'être
législatif parce que je considère
personnellement que si nous prenons des
décrets au Conseil d'État et il y a une
petite conflit d'intérêt dans notre
histoire mais on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler sans doute dans nos débats donc
moi je tiens à ces quatrième procédure
j'espère dans les débats et dans vos
éditions démontrer son intérêt sur
Madame madame gendarme dit bon alors
voilà vous priorisez les les personnes
dangereuses pour le bien public vous
mettez vos rétablissez à double peine
mais du coup comment on fait avec tous
les autres puisque grosso modo vous
mettez et pas les autres alors la
difficulté qui est mise à l'intérieur et
surtout lorsqu'il est arrivé il y a deux
ans et demi c'est qu'il y avait pas
beaucoup de place de cras pour pour deux
grandes raisons la première c'est qu'un
la structurellement pas beaucoup en
France alors comparativement à d'autres
pays européens il y en a beaucoup mais
comparativement sans doute un petit
d'expulsion
et puis deuxièmement je suis arrivé au 8
avatar au moment du covid ou les
restrictions sanitaires s'appliquaient
également bien sûr en place de crabe
puis troisièmement répondre à votre
question assis pour les mineurs
qu'est-ce qui prend de la place dans
l'écran également et pour d'autres
raisons je pourrais évoquer pourquoi il
faudrait supprimer en effet la présence
des personnes de moins de 16 ans dans
les centres de rétention administratives
c'est pas nécessaire dans son métier par
une petite migratoire efficace parce
qu'il y a des lieux familles et c'est du
famille ils prennent des places que
pourrait être libéré largement pour les
délinquants étrangers qui sont à 98% des
hommes je suis obligé de le constater
avec vous donc le but de l'intérieur il
avait pas cette place structurellement
pas cette place à cause covid et par
ailleurs des lieux familles où il n'y a
personne ou pas grand monde puisque je
voudrais dire voler les chiffres à
madame la sénatrice en 2022 il y a eu
107 mineurs en métropole donc voilà la
question qui se pose c'est Mayotte on
reparler évidemment si vous le souhaitez
mais en métropole en fait on a une
politique migratoire sans mettre des
mineurs dans les centres de rétention
administratifs bien évidemment j'aurais
reparlé donc d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on
essaye de faire d'abord on essaie de
dire parmi les priorités parce que quand
il y a des difficultés on essaie de
faire des priorités moi je pense qu'il
vaut mieux concentrer nos moyens pour
expulser des étrangers qui sont en
situation irrégulière qui sont
délinquants que l'étranger institution
régulière qui n'est pas délinquant
d'ailleurs je vais pas faire ici de
Revit de détail mais je reçois
énormément de lettres de tout bord
politique pour me dire moi j'ai un je
connais un jeune Malien 19 ans qui est
formidable dans ma boulangerie il faut
vraiment le régulariser ou j'ai une
infirmière voilà cette infirmière elle
est formidable régularisée donc je
constate qu'il y a souvent des
différences entre la position qu'on a en
général sur les étrangers et les
interventions individuelles de chacune
et de chacun
j'ai été Parlement j'ai été
parlementaire j'ai moi-même péché un
maximum mais elle coule pas enfin je
suis bien obligé de le constater bon et
rarement vous m'écrivez pour me dire je
connais un étranger délinquant très bien
il faut me le régulariser en général
vous ne fait pas sur ce point et donc je
me dis tiens peut-être que dans la la
liste des personnes que je dois expulser
en premier devant les difficultés
évidemment d'expulser des étrangers
notamment dans le cadre du covid je me
suis dit on va d'abord expulser les
étrangers en situation régulière qui
sont délinquants alors soit qui relèvent
du fsprt je rappelle qu'il y a pas si
longtemps que ça de payer était très
touché par le terrorisme et il est
toujours extrêmement menacé par le
terrorisme soit qu'on appelle nous les
tops c'est-à-dire les étrangers
délinquants de droit commun
tout à l'heure le président du fait me
demandait une péto combien de personnes
sont concernées on a exp + C 800
étrangers inscrits au fsrt
depuis que je suis au ministère de
l'Intérieur et 3500 délinquants
étrangers c'est-à-dire qu'on a multiplié
par 7 le nombre d'étrangers délinquants
qu'on a pu expulser pourquoi parce qu'on
est fait comme vous l'avez dit dans mon
instruction que j'ai donné au préfet au
centre de rétention administratif
j'ai décidé de mettre en priorité quand
on a deux dossiers quelqu'un qui est
dangereux plutôt quelqu'un qui est pas
dangereux parce que si quelqu'un qui est
dangereux qu'attend son expulsion comme
était des crimes vous seriez les
premiers et vous auriez raison bien
pourquoi il est pas ailleurs que dans un
centre de rétention administratif
ceci étant dit
nous avons
conscience que nous ne pouvons pas
mettre que des étrangers dit dangereux
dans les centres de rétrosion
administrative et que ces centres de
rétention administratives ont aussi un
intérêt bien sûr pour les étrangers qui
n'ont pas de casier judiciaire mais qui
méritent d'être expulsé du territoire
national c'est pour ça que nous avons
adopté un amendement du Parlement c'est
en l'occurrence à un moment national que
vous avez confirmé ici même en CMP pour
la création de 3000 places de CRA donc
depuis que je suis mise intérieur en
augmenter de 800 le nombre de places de
CRA deuxième
instruction de ne plus mettre des
mineurs dans les cas donc du coup je
gagne encore des places de centre de
rétention administratif puisque l'espace
famille devient un espace homme je gagne
de la place je maintiens aussi à sa
forme de crack qui était je pense au
département du président de la
commission des lois puisqu'on a ouvert
un cra à Lyon j'ai décidé de laisser
ouvert l'ancien après rénovation avec
une innovation pour la première fois
depuis de très nombreuses années c'est
les gendarmes qui tiennent le Kra et
plus simplement les policiers aux
frontières et puis de nombreux projets
évidemment existent encore donc
je pense que cette priorité aux
étrangers délinquants dans à partir de
l'année prochaine je crois madame la
sénatrice je pense qu'on peut le dire ne
sera pas exclusif dans les centres de la
tension administrative parce que le
Mesnil-Amelot il y en a vers Perpignan
il y en a donc j'en ai dit à Lyon il y
en a un nouveau en Île-de-France vont
permettre d'avoir plus de place de gras
et donc plus de possibilités d'y mettre
des personnes y compris qui ne sont pas
étrangers délinquants il y a aussi des
LRA
donc ces lieux de rétention
administratif je les ai demandé au
préfet n'en faisait pas assez notamment
dans le sud de la France donc c'est les
rats nous permettent de mettre justement
des personnes qui sont pas en tant que
tel dangereuses et permettre justement
de mettre des personnes qui sont en
attente des expulsions et pour répondre
à votre question ce qui est écrit dans
le texte c'est le centre de rétention
administratif pour les mineurs mais il
peut toujours avoir des locaux
administratifs de rétention bien sûr des
lieux comme des LRA de rétention on peut
même imaginer dans certains cas
particuliers des endroits des
assignations à résidence ou cette ou la
maison ou l'appartement évidemment est
gardé par la police nationale quelle est
la difficulté d'appuyer ce frontières la
police aux frontière sa difficulté c'est
pas de garder pendant des semaines des
enfants de 6-7 ans dans un lieu clos
avec des barbelés je pense que chacun
comprend que c'est pas de ma manière de
se construire
mais en même temps on voit bien que la
difficulté c'est que la veille de
prendre l'avion il faut pas que
évidemment les personnes utilisent ce
moment où ils ont relative liberté pour
pouvoir s'échapper et se soustraire au
contrôle de la police donc le monde dans
lequel je voudrais qu'on évolue si
jamais le Sénat et l'Assemblée venait à
adopter ces dispositions dans le cas où
une famille et notamment je parle il
s'agit là peut-être d'enfants en bas âge
bien évidemment devait être expulsé du
territoire national et bien la veille
voir même l'avant veille mais je pense
que on sait tout à fait capable de faire
la veille dans un lieu de rétention
spécifique un hôtel par exemple qui est
près d'un aéroport garder par la police
permet de pouvoir avoir sous la main si
j'ose dire la famille mais ne pas
imposer aux jeunes enfants des images de
centre qui sont quand même assez
carcéraux voilà donc je pense qu'on est
capable de dire pas d'enfants dans les
cas et en même temps d'avoir dans des
locaux de de rétention plus humaine de
plus humains pardon je commence à être
fatigué des gens qui peuvent être gardés
par la police pour évidemment qu'il ne
se soucerait pas au contrôle évidemment
et on renvoie dans leur pays d'origine
enfin sur la question plus générale des
laisser passer consulaires contre les
visas votre question est évidemment
au milieu la difficulté du métier de
mise à l'intérieur et d'immigration
monsieur le rapporteur mais vous le
savez bien moi je n'ai rien
contredisposition législative et
j'allais dire même au contraire j'ai
tout pour édition législatives pourquoi
parce que quand je discute avec mes
homologues étrangers ils me disent nous
on respecte les lois de la République on
respecte les lois de votre pays mais
c'est pas dans les votes de votre pays
que ces visas contre la mission donc
j'allais vous dire puisque j'ai parfois
entendu cet argument de la part de mes
homologues contact ça me paraît bizarre
de mettre des quotas au sens des quotas
de visa réadmissions à partir de quand
on peut déclencher je voudrais qu'on en
parle-t-il un petit peu plus mais qui
est une disposition générale qui disent
voilà la République elle peut pas
accepter de pas avoir de laisser passer
le consulaire un échange faire du visa
moi j'y suis personnellement pas du tout
pas du tout posé juste peut-être pour
être plus efficace mais pardon d'être un
peu long monsieur le Président Monsieur
pour être très important faut savoir que
la relation diplomatique entre deux pays
c'est pas qu'entre deux ministres de
l'Intérieur malheureusement j'allais
dire et que la discussion diplomatique
elle se fait pas entre laisser passer
consulat votre visa c'est déjà très
compliqué parce que Visa pour qui visa
pourquoi vous me dites avec gentillesse
on a trouvé que la France est très très
courageuse quand tu as fait des
réflexions de visa je voudrais pas ici
aussi de redire que tout en encourageant
la restriction de visa en général contre
des laisser passer consulaires qui
n'était pas donné je ne compte plus le
nom de l'interventions de parlementaire
qui lui est quand même ce que vous
faites avec le Maroc ou avec l'Algérie
avec nos ça nous embête beaucoup
politiquement culturellement
économiquement du compteur des parts de
marché dans ces pays bon on peut pas
l'ignorer non plus que nous avons aussi
parfois cette singulière pression mais
par ailleurs il y a d'autres sujets je
pense au développement je sors
complètement de mon rôle mais peut-être
qu'on pourrait penser que et là ma
position n'a pas été validé on a terminé
comme on dit est-ce que on peut trouver
normal que des pays nous refusent et
laisser passer consulaire et qu'on leur
donne beaucoup d'aide de développement
alors que manifestement il n'acceptent
pas le retour de leurs étrangers en
situation irrégulière c'est une question
importante intéressante qu'on va se
poser donc si vous faites un amendement
monsieur le sénateur je ne saurais trop
vous recommandé de regarder l'ensemble
de la politique de notre pays et pas
simplement des relations entre les
intérieure parce que quel problème ils
intérieur quand il discute avec son
homologue c'est qu'il parle et c'est
passé consulaire mais parle aussi de
coopération antiterroriste il parle
aussi de renseignements de coopération
judiciaire et que parfois il vaut mieux
la sécurité des Français que de se
fâcher sur une question de visa de
rémission mais si le Parlement je ne
fais qu'appliquer les lois du du
Parlement s'il va le voter je pense que
ce serait à mon avis une bonne pierre
pour les futurs négociations des mises à
l'intérieur
point monsieur bonnecarer n'aura pas de
mal à retrouver dans ces tablettes un
amendement qui a été voté en 2018 un
initiative de votre serviteurs qui
n'avait pas eu de bonne suite mais je me
souviens d'une question d'actualité à
laquelle vous aviez répondu
favorablement à cette idée on va la
reprendre naturellement Monsieur duple
Merci monsieur le Président sur les deux
points évoqués par les rapporteurs
d'abord sur la question de Madame
Jourdan est-ce qu'il est normal en tout
cas je réformer votre interrogation que
l'employeur prenne en charge les
conséquences d'une politique migratoire
je ne partage pas l'entrée dans dans la
discussion dans ce sujet pour deux
raisons d'abord nous parlons uniquement
des étrangers non communautaires et il
faut savoir ça permet de relativiser
l'importance ou le volume de ce dont
nous parlons que les étrangers non
communautaire occupent moins de 4% du
total de l'emploi en France c'est très
variable d'un métier à l'autre mais en
moyenne on est autour de 3,8%.
l'étranger communautaire parmi le total
des salariés sur le territoire français
et donc ça ça permet d'avoir une cible
si je puis dire relativement modeste
sachant que parmi eux beaucoup se
constitutions régulières depuis très
longtemps et ont déjà satisfait aux
obligations d'intégration et de maîtrise
du français la deuxième chose c'est que
nous parlons justement d'étrangers non
communautaire et donc la présence de ces
étrangers dans les entreprises et est à
la fois le fruit des décisions de
recrutement avec une nuance que
j'apporte moi-même dans mon propos c'est
que nous sommes actuellement dans une
période de tension de recrutement ce qui
peut amener à des choix particuliers ou
différents de ceux que les chefs
d'entreprises faisaient précédemment
mais c'est une présence qui est choisie
par celui qui recrute par le recrutement
d'un étranger donc communautaire et
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'entreprises le
disaient tout à l'heure nous invite à
aller même plus avant que ce que nous
proposons le MIH qui a communiqué
aujourd'hui dit à la fois soutenir et
vouloir aller plus loin en matière
régularisation de salariés réguliers
mais dans la présence sur le territoire
était régulière et nous demande même de
faciliter les conditions d'entrée sur le
territoire ce qui n'est pas prévu euh
par ce texte au-delà de la
simplification de la carte talent que
j'ai déjà évoqué l'étape est déjà
beaucoup en matière de formation
beaucoup en matière de formation dans la
mesure où avant même la mise en oeuvre
de la loopmie des moyens supplémentaires
consacrés à l'insertion et l'intégration
par la langue il y a des dizaines de
milliers de places de formation en
français qui sont ouvertes par l'État et
qui permettent à des étrangères
allophones de pouvoir se former et ainsi
d'acquérir un niveau de français et par
ailleurs au-delà du temps libéré et des
quelques heures de temps de travail que
nous allons demander aux employeurs
concernés de libérer pour permettre le
suivi des cours nous souhaitons aussi
que les différentes entreprises et les
branches professionnelles puissent
s'intégrer nous proposons d'écrire de
manière explicite la possibilité
d'inscrire dans leur plan de formation
dans leur plan de développement des
compétences des modules spécifiques pour
leurs salariés allophones puisqu'il y a
des salariés hello fun et prévoir que
les plans de formation débranchent comme
les entreprises puissent prévoir des
modules spécifiques pour les salariés
hellophobes sera aussi une réponse à
portée apporter à ceci je crois que
d'une manière peut-être plus générale ou
si on sort du Sud du seul sujet de
financement
par la libération du temps de
compétences il y a quelques remarques
que l'on peut faire aussi d'abord une
marque pour dire que le caractère un peu
contraignant de cette libération de
temps pour participer à des obligations
des formations en français limite le
côté armé de raisin et le côté recours
avec main d'oeuvre étrangère non
communautaire avec comme objectif et une
pression à la baisse des salaires la
deuxième remarque est que nous avons
beaucoup réfléchi autour de ce sujet là
pour voir comment demander aux
entreprises qui par ailleurs nous
demandent d'avoir plus facilement accès
au recrutement de salarié non
communautaire de participer à la
formation française et nous avons fait
le choix de vous proposer le fait de
libérer du temps sur le temps de travail
plutôt que de créer une nouvelle taxe
qui aurait pu être imaginé pour financer
ces mêmes formations et le temps le
temps nécessaire et enfin il y a un
dernier point que que je porte à votre
réflexion qui est le fait que dans le
code du travail tel qu'il s'a que les
salariés soient français européens ou
non communautaires l'employeur est une
obligation de formation pour
l'adaptation des salariés au poste
occupé et pour les salariés allophones
ça renvoie aussi à la maîtrise de la
langue nécessaire pour à la fois la
compréhension des instructions et la
communication avec l'ensemble des
équipes
cela fait le lien d'une certaine manière
quand on parle d'obligation avec les
interrogations de monsieur le sénateur
bonne Carrère sur l'article 3 quel est
notre objectif notre objectif n'est pas
de susciter un flux de manière très
claire et je partage comme vous le fait
qu'il n'y a pas d'appel d'air avec ce
titre de séjour nouveau pas d'appel
d'air parce qu'il faudrait pour qu'il y
en appelle d'air que des étrangers
communautaires non communautaires pardon
ayant connaissance de l'existence d'un
titre de séjour spécifique prennent la
décision de venir sur le territoire
national avec l'objectif de s'y
maintenir en situation irrégulière
pendant au moins trois ans en l'état du
texte d'exercer un métier pendant au
moins 8 mois en l'état du texte dans une
filière en tension et en ayant une
espèce de pré connaissance trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans à l'avance de l'état
de la liste des métiers en tension
puisque cette liste émettant attention à
vocation à être renouvelée et révisée
intervalle régulier lorsqu'on a dit cela
est râpé ces critères d'accès au titre
des séjours la question de l'appel d'air
ne se pose pas véritablement
il y a une question que vous avez posée
par contre qui renvoie puisqu'on est sur
une logique de régularisation de
salariés qui ont un contrat de travail
qui ont une activité régulière mais une
situation personnelle irrégulière qui
renvoie à la question des sanctions pour
l'employeur il est bien évident et je
préfère le préciser devant vous que les
employeurs qui verraient dans leurs
effectifs des personnes en situation
irrégulière obtenir une régularisation
par ce type de séjour qui employeur qui
ne connaissent pas la situation
administrative de leur salarié il n'y a
pas lieu de les sanctionner ça n'existe
pas dans notre esprit ça doit pas
exister dans l'application la volonté
que nous avons de renforcer les
sanctions concernent les employeurs qui
délibérément recrutent des personnes en
situation irrégulière et et là le fait
de créer une sanction administrative
permet aussi à la fois la
proportionnalité et une liberté
d'appréciation de l'autorité
administrative j'ai dit à descendre tout
à l'heure que beaucoup des personnes en
situation irrégulière mais travaillant
régulièrement sont des personnes qui en
réalité ont signé un un travail à un
moment où ils étaient titulaires d'un
titre de séjour avec celui-ci n'a pas
été renouvelé nous ne pouvons pas en
faire grief au chef d'entreprise de
manière automatique ça serait injuste
d'une certaine manière lui-même ne le
s'en charge pas forcément et je le dis
en ajoutant qu'il arrive parfois même à
l'état de devoir mettre fin à des
contrats de travail découvrant que tel
ou tel contractuel a perdu le bénéfice
d'un titre de séjour et donc ça nous
amène aussi une forme d'humilité de
compréhension de la situation des
employeurs dans le secteur privé et donc
c'est vraiment
l'articulation vous cherchez entre
l'article 3 et l'article 8 n'existe pas
en réalité puisque l'article 8 vise
véritablement à sanctionner plus
fortement ceux qui délibérément de
manière réitère en recours à des
personnes en situation irrégulière pour
pour les employés sur la question de
l'amélioration du texte pour permettre
notamment au Parlement
d'avoir une capacité d'évaluation qui
soit améliorée vous avez évoqué la
limitation vous avez évoqué la question
du calendrier moi je regarderai avec
évidemment beaucoup d'attention
les initiatives parlementaires en la
matière pour voir comment on peut
apporter les garanties que certains ont
certaines d'entre vous souhaiteraient
exiger et donc ça n'est pas une réponse
en disant nous avons une disposition
sinon nous l'aurions inscrite dans la
loi mais évidemment nous sommes
favorables à y travailler et il y a une
question que vous avez évoquée ensuite
qui est
deux questions pardon et j'en terminerai
par là qui concerne d'une part le
caractère opposable du titre de séjour
et finalement
le fait que un employeur puisse
découvrir ou voir apparaître dans ses
effectifs quelqu'un qui aurait demandé
au juge administratif l'obtention d'un
titre de séjour pour métier en tension
si d'aventure la préfecture au prix de
qui est la sollicité ne l'avait pas
attribué je pense que le fait de mettre
dans la loi comme nous vous le proposons
des critères d'éligibilité à ce type de
séjour en matière de renvoi une liste de
métiers en tension qui fait l'objet
d'une décision administrative
puisqu'elle fait l'objet d'une
publication par arrêter ministérielle le
fait d'inscrire dans la loi les critères
d'ancienneté tant dans l'occupation de
l'emploi que sur la
présent sur le territoire et de
déterminer par la loi comme nous vous le
proposons ce qui relève des critères
retenus au titre de la présence sur le
territoire est-ce qu'il en relève pas
notamment dans le cadre de ceux qui ont
un moment ou un autre été demandeurs
d'asile c'est la meilleure garantie
qu'il n'y ait pas véritablement
d'opposable ou que ça ne soit pas de
possibilités ou que ce ne soit pas un
nid à contentieux puisque nous proposons
contrairement à la circulaire Malte
notamment qui relève de discrétionnaire
nous proposerons au Parlement de fixer
les critères de manière extrêmement
précise sur qui a droit ou pas à la
carte et je pense que ça diminue le
risque de contentieux et l'employeur ne
serait pas tenu ni au paiement d'une
sanction ni à la délivrance d'un CDI
s'il ne le souhaite pas puisque il est
libre évidemment de donner de proposer
et de signer un CDI ou pas avec son
salarié
la deuxième chose que vous avez évoquée
et dont je parle lequel je termine
concerne la question des trappes à bas
salaires aujourd'hui en réalité c'est la
situation que nous connaissons qui est
une forme de trappe à bas salaire le
fait que un certain nombre de salariés
en situation régulière puisse être dans
une suite dans une d'avoir une présence
sur le territoire qui elle est
irrégulière l'aimait peut les mettre en
tout cas dans une situation de
vulnérabilité et cette situation du
vulnérabilité est plutôt la cause de la
trappe à bas salaire à l'inverse la
régularisation et l'obtention d'un titre
de séjour oblige à minima au salaire
minima au minimum conventionnel de
branche et permet d'aligner pardon pour
l'expression les conditions d'emploi de
ces personnes sur les conditions
d'emploi prévues par les conventions
collectives donc c'est plutôt un aspect
protecteur je pense plutôt que créateur
de trappe à bas salaire et je n'inclus
pas dans la réflexion même si ça existe
sur le territoire les personnes qui sont
dans une double situation de travail non
déclaré et de situations irrégulière
pour lesquelles il peut y avoir
notamment de la part d'employeur
particulièrement délinquants des
situations de d'exploitation et parfois
même d'asservissement vous avez renvoyé
à l'idée d'un rôle des branches et d'une
forme de négociation collective
je ne pense pas que nous puissions la
retenir pour la définition des métiers
en tension dans la mesure où il y a un
appareil statistique qui permet d'après
la loi qui crée la liste des habitants
tension de mesurer les tensions de
recrutement par contre pour ce qui
concerne
l'accompagnement l'intégration et y
compris les questions relatives à la
formation des salariés concernés je
pense qu'effectivement et sans me
substituer aux partenaires sociaux qui
gère ses accords de branche évidemment
je pense qu'il serait utile
effectivement que les partenaires
sociaux fassent ce travail branche par
branche pour prévoir des modalités
d'accompagnement et de bonnes
intégration des salariés et ainsi
apporter un certain nombre de réponses
aux interrogations que vous avez
partagées merci Monsieur le livre pour
cette réponse complète on va donner la
parole aux uns et aux autres alors
Monsieur Alain Richard monsieur
Jean-Yves Lecomte Madame Brigitte
l'herbier madame Jacquinot strange
brignot Madame Valérie Boyer et Monsieur
Philippe de Brest
monsieur Richard
il serait de l'Intérieur est-ce que vous
pensez que les réformes les
améliorations qui figurent dans ce
projet de loi
permettront de limiter le flux des
mineurs
isolés entrant en France à travers un
système organisé qui soit artisanal ou
qu'il soit malheureusement
un système beaucoup plus large et
mafieux
sachant que une partie de ces entrées se
font
de façon irrégulière elle-même elle ne
passe pas par la police de la rue des
frontières ni en France ni dans un autre
pays d'entrée et par conséquent est-ce
que vous voyez d'autres outils qui
permettraient de freiner ce mouvement
parce que je crains quand même qu'il
souhaite en croissance
notamment à travers une meilleure amie
repérage de
l'identité réelle de ces jeunes
merci féministe monsieur Jean-Yves
Lecomte merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur des ministres
5 5 points la vie du Conseil d'État il
est indiqué sur la renouvellement des
titres pluriannuels que près d'un quart
des étrangers qui suivent la formation
linguistique n'atteint pas le niveau A1
à l'insu à l'issue du parcours
d'intégration républicaine alors qu'elle
était éligible à une carte de séjour
pluriannuelle est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'avec la disposition qui est prévue
dans le projet de loi finalement on
allait on va précariser la situation de
personnes qui sont incapables finalement
de de répondre à cette exigence alors
que souvent finalement pour arriver à se
débrouiller en France ils ont besoin
finalement de l'accompagnement de leurs
enfants est-ce que c'est vraiment en
précarisant qu'on intègre deuxième
question sur les guichets asiles
sans avoir d'objections de principe je
m'interroge vraiment sur un point
comment prendre en compte dans les
préfectures à la question de la
vulnérabilité dès lors que on saute
l'étape finalement de la rédaction d'un
récit et que tout se fait finalement à
la préfecture comment est-ce qu'on gère
la vulnérabilité en particulier en
donnant la possibilité d'être accueilli
par une personne de l'offrey qui serait
du même sexe que le que le demandeur et
en matière d'interprétariat et deuxième
question liée à ces guichets asiles
comment est-ce que vous ne ferez pas
compte tenu des difficultés de de cette
partie de ce qui se passerait dans les
guichets préfecture l'étape limitante
qui limiterait le nombre de rendez-vous
dans les préfectures et qui finalement
allongerait les capacités
rendrai plus difficile les capacités des
préfectures d'accueillir un maximum de
demandeurs de demande d'asile dans un
temps limité sur la question des
régularisations
qu'est-ce que vous faites finalement des
autres dispositions de la circulaire
valse c'est ce que la circulaire vase
sera remplacée puisque il y a une partie
des choses qui seront traitées par un
titre de plein droit qu'est-ce que vous
faites avec cette avec les autres les
autres aspects comment vous traitez
malgré tout la situation des
travailleurs des plateformes parce que
c'est pas parce que demain on a interdit
à une personne en situation irrégulière
de devenir auto-entrepreneur qui en a
pas qu'ils l'ont fait auparavant on ne
résout pas finalement l'ensemble des
difficultés avec la disposition que vous
prenez sur les
autos en trouvant sans solution
je suis aussi assez étonné ça fait un
petit peu de temps que je fais la
commission des lois mais petit à petit
on parlait bon on parlait beaucoup des
centres de rétention administrative
depuis quelques mois on parle des LRA
des lieux de rétention administrative
qui sont moins identifiés moins connus
pas vérifie pas alors est-ce que c'est
une ce serait quand même assez
préoccupant d'avoir de plus en plus de
lieux de privation des libertés dans
notre pays sans qu'il soit réellement
identifié est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
à revoir de ce point de vue là parce que
c'est une inquiétude on on va de plus en
plus regarder ce qui se passe dans
l'écran et voilà d'autres lieux de
privation de liberté semblent de plus en
plus se développer vous l'indiquez
d'ailleurs dans une de vos circulaires
du mois de du mois d'août enfin dernière
question
vous avez évoqué les aspects européens
il y a quelques l'année dernière on
pensait que le système entrée sortie
Schengen Ethias serait mis en place
avant la fin de cette année le dernier
Conseil européen nous indique que ça
sera mis en place aussi vite que
possible ce qui veut dire en langage
européen qu'on a pas de délai donc voilà
qu'est-ce qui se passe réellement de ce
côté là est-ce que ça sera réellement
mis en place avant les JO
merci Monsieur Leconte Madame Brigitte
l'herbier puis madame Serge Brignoud
monsieur le ministre je voudrais revenir
sur l'ordre public
justement ces derniers temps on en a
parlé d'autant plus beaucoup de
nouvelles drogues beaucoup de produits
stupéfiants sur le sol français
se développent beaucoup de reportages
qui nous montrent que les jeunes
africains en situation irrégulière font
venir sur le sol français des produits
toujours nouveaux toujours plus plus
dangereux alors moi ce qui me
m'interroge c'est savoir si
diplomatiquement on peut pas avoir des
des prérogatifs plus sévères concernant
ces ces pays concernant le
l'intégration de de ces de ces
ressortissants
il me semble difficile d'envisager la
régularisation de de nombreux jeunes de
tel ou tel pays sachant que
beaucoup de filières s'organisent avec
ces pays et une deuxième remarque
concerne justement tout à l'heure vous
disiez on a eu beaucoup de familles qui
viennent nous voir c'est vrai dans les
permanences
concernant justement souvent c'est des
instituteurs qui nous disent les enfants
sont bien intégrés à l'école
ils font des études
au collège au lycée voire même
deviennent ingénieurs je pense que ça
fait partie aussi de l'intégration que
de de remarquer ça que de remarquer que
les parents peuvent il y a pas seulement
le
l'apprentissage du français il y a aussi
la responsabilisation des parents et je
pense que dans toutes ces
remarques il faut en prendre compte
aussi
parce que c'est quand même assez gênant
parce que même économiquement à la
limite ces jeunes qui deviennent
ingénieurs qui deviennent médecins ça
peut être aussi intéressant pour pour
notre pays merci Madame c'est la triste
madame Jacky le singe Bruno oui merci
monsieur le Président je vais essayer
d'être rapide mais c'est un sujet qui me
passionne parce que je suis une attrice
de l'Île-de-France et on sait que en
gros 50% des premiers admigration sont
en Île-de-France donc je me sens
extrêmement concernée par ce texte deux
choses pour Monsieur ministre du ZOP moi
sur l'article 3 j'ai évidemment de
grosses grosses résistances pour deux
raisons la première c'est que je ne sais
pas trop ce que ce sont les métiers en
tension en tout cas nous les Français
nous tous les métiers sont en tension
donc partout on cherche du personnel de
l'emploi enfin bon il y a des emplois
qui pourraient être aujourd'hui
voilà moi il y a un sujet de Fond vous
me dites que vous avez parlé discuter
avec des représentants du monde patronal
voilà des organisations patronales je
pense que d'abord si on se faisait la
question du niveau des salaires pour
certains certains effectivement emplois
seraient pourvu aujourd'hui sans
problème c'est une vraie question c'est
une vraie question et moi ce qui me gêne
beaucoup dans cet article 3 c'est qu'on
va provoquer une espèce de main d'oeuvre
sous-payée ou peu payer quand même très
docile qui évidemment va pas gêner les
employeurs alors c'est une femme de
droite qui parle aujourd'hui mais c'est
un vrai sujet vous êtes aujourd'hui en
train de vivre exactement ce qu'a vécu
le président Giscard d'Estaing avec le
regroupement familial quand il a cédé
aux pression des employeurs et du
patronat qui leur disent qu'il le disait
à l'époque il faut absolument en faire
le grand familial parce qu'autrement
tous les employés d'origine d'engins
nous avons vont repartir c'est la même
chose aujourd'hui on se pose pas la
question de fond du pourquoi aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de branches
professionnelles veulent absolument cet
article 3 pour régulariser du personnel
si elles ont aujourd'hui des personnes
qu'elles emploient des personnes en
situation régulière il y a quand même la
circulaire Vans qui permet un certain
nombre de choses et les préfectures y
travaillent je connais vraiment ce sujet
les préfectures essayent de régulariser
via la circulaire vase donc moi j'ai un
vrai sujet et puis sur la responsabilité
du de du patronat en général est-ce que
vous avez abordé avec eux la
problématique de logement d'intégration
de tous ces gens ça de problème à
personne qu'un certain nombre
de personnes étrangères vivent à 5-6
dans un 20 mètres carrés c'est un vrai
sujet ça pose pas souvent de problèmes
aux employeurs ça voilà donc ça c'est un
vrai sujet et en Île de France c'est un
vrai sujet monsieur le ministre Darmanin
a parlé des marchands de sommeil c'est
une réalité c'est une réalité et je
pense que il y a pas de quoi être fier
de dire on va donner des titres et puis
après ben effectivement qui vivent à 5
dans 20m2 c'est pas notre problème bah
si c'est le nôtre en tout cas c'est le
problème de la France donc pour moi
c'est un vrai sujet et cet article 3 me
pose un vrai problème intellectuel un
problème de respect et moi je
cautionnerai absolument pas un article
qui permettrait d'avoir une main
d'oeuvre sous-payée mais qui arrange
tout le monde ça c'est un vrai sujet
c'est un peu je vais aller très loin
mais l'esclavagisme du 21e siècle alors
deuxième question deuxième sujet c'est
pour Monsieur Darmanin je voudrais
savoir si un certain nombre d'accord
avec certains pays que nous avons ne
vont pas gêner l'applicabilité réelle de
la loi sur lequel nous discutons
aujourd'hui par exemple l'accord
franco-algérien il y a d'autres accords
il y a encore franco-marocain et à la
coffre en côte tunisien mais celui qui à
mon avis il va perturber l'application
de ce texte intégralement c'est l'accord
franco-algérien est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre il y a une
nécessité une légitimité à garder ses
accords ou n'y a-t-il pas un intérêt à
dénoncer ses accords pour que toutes ces
lois s'appliquent partout de la même
manière ça c'est un vrai pour moi c'est
une vraie question c'est un vrai sujet
parce qu'on sait bien les difficultés
que nous avons avec certains nombres de
pays en particulier et puis il m'a grève
mais d'autres mais qui a un certain
nombre d'accords qui nous gênent pour
aller jusqu'au bout que nous des choses
voilà que nous écrivons aujourd'hui et
juste une toute petite question et vous
avez parlé monsieur le ministre monsieur
du fait que un certain nombre
d'étrangers seraient sanctionnés
lorsqu'il refuserait
de
d'aller voir un médecin femme ou homme
enfin bon bref on connaît les problèmes
que nous avons dans nos hôpitaux ça
c'est un vrai sujet vous avez eu raison
de le poser mais est-ce que vous vous
êtes aussi posé la question des médecins
parce que nous accueillons dans nos
hôpitaux et en région parisienne
beaucoup qui viennent d'étrangers ça
c'est pas un souci c'est vraiment pas un
souci mais je ne suis pas sûr que tous
ces médecins respectent les règles de la
République et écoles de la République
également parce que d'ailleurs il y a eu
un rapport qui a été fait l'année
dernière sur ce sujet sur la difficulté
aussi que certains hôpitaux vivent avec
certains médecins qui ne sont pas les
premiers à imposer et respecter les
règles de la République dans leur
fonctionnement de médecins et je pense
que ça c'est un vrai sujet aussi c'est
un sujet qu'il faudra aborder et c'est
un sujet qu'il faut poser
merci madame la sénatrice Madame Valérie
Boyer puis Monsieur dobress Merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres je crois savoir au moment même
où nous parlons monsieur les ministres
que l'Algérie a suspendu la délivrance
de laisser passer consulaire c'était une
petite remarque
voilà alors moi ma question porte sur le
trafic d'être humain
vous le savez les Nations unies estiment
à 32 milliards de dollars par an dans le
monde dont 3 milliards pour l'Europe les
profits générés par la traite des êtres
humains au regard de ces chiffres ce
trafic est le troisième le plus lucratif
pour les organisations criminelles après
le trafic de stupéfiants et celui
d'armes la France du fait de sa position
géographique est aujourd'hui à la fois
un pays recevant des victimes de ces
trafics mais aussi un pays de transit de
ces trafics et ne pas agir c'est de
venir complice vous avez d'ailleurs
évoqué votre volonté de mettre fin à ces
trafics puisque vous le savez les
filières de passeurs sont devenues des
experts en détournement de procédure et
c'est vrai que ces personnes exploitent
les failles de notre système et abusent
de la générosité nationale et
contrairement à ce que certains disent
ce ne sont pas les frontières qui tuent
la France n'est pas coupable de tout
cela elle a le droit de protéger ses
frontières et doit mener un véritable
combat contre ceux qui prostituent
profitent violent vol et exploite les
migrants pour combattre ces passeurs ce
n'est pas une simplification de sécurité
mais ça doit être aussi un devoir de
dignité de notre part aujourd'hui c'est
pasteurs sont beaucoup mieux organisés
qu'avant juridiquement le trafic des
migrants est dissocié de la traite des
êtres humains alors que dans la majorité
des TK c'est deux phénomènes sont liés
puisqu'il s'appuie sur l'exploitation de
l'amendicité de personnes vulnérables
qui tentent de fuir par tout moyen leur
pays ou qui s'organisent pour envoyer
notamment des mineurs chez nous aussi
dès 2015 j'avais déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale une proposition de loi visant
à renforcer la lutte contre ces trafics
de migrants malheureusement ces
propositions de loi que j'ai toujours
formulées à travers des PPL ou des
amendements toujours été rejetés
notamment dans la loi colon mais
permettez-moi de voir encore qu'une fois
des années après le gouvernement reprend
ses propositions je m'en réjouis en
partie et aujourd'hui le fait que pour
toute personne de facilité ou tenter de
faciliter par être directe ou indirect
l'entrée la circulation ou le séjour
irrégulier d'un étranger en France
constitue un délit puni de 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 30000 euros
d'amende c'est vrai que j'avais proposé
de renforcer ces sanctions prévues par
le cza contre ces trafiquants passeurs
avec la même sévérité que pour les
trafiquants d'être humain je me félicite
de voir que huit ans après vous reprenez
cette proposition alors que vos
prédécesseurs si on sont toujours
opposés monsieur le ministre j'ai deux
petites questions précises à ce sujet
pourquoi est-ce qui était absurde en
2015 et 2018 ne l'est plus aujourd'hui
pourquoi avoir perdu autant de temps
mais plus précisément pourquoi ne pas
renforcer les sanctions pour l'ensemble
des trafiquants d'être humain en effet
votre réforme ne concerne que les
suivante j'en ai noté deux vous me direz
si j'ai je me suis trompé ou pas ça
concerne le fait quand les étrangers
auront été exposés à un risque immédiat
de mort ou de blessures de nature à
entraîner une mutilation une infirmité
permanente et ça ne touche que les
dirigeants ou les organisations de ces
groupesments et enfin j'ai une dernière
question qui va dans le sens de ce que
Monsieur le Ministre Richard vous a posé
tout à l'heure c'est à dire une
interrogation sur les mineurs étrangers
isolées est-ce que c'est mineur qui pour
la plupart accèdent à la nationalité
française à l'issue de leur séjour dans
dans les
accueillis par les départements vont
continuer à accéder quasi
automatiquement à la nationalité
française après votre texte parce que
bien évidemment l'accès la nationalité
française de ces mineurs étrangers
isolés posent de véritables problèmes de
trafic d'être humain puisque on sait
très bien que c'est une filière
merci à tous monsieur le sénateur
monsieur le ministre de Brest oui je
vais très rapide vu l'heure monsieur le
Président est-ce que Monsieur Miss
Darmanin peut nous en dire plus sur les
conditions de restriction du
regroupement familial sur lequel il est
passé assez rapidement je comprends il y
a beaucoup de sujets et c'est quand même
un sujet central et qui fait toujours
l'objet de polémique haut Parlement qui
fait toujours l'objet de discussion avec
le Conseil d'État de conseil
constitutionnel et ce qui peut nous dire
où il a mis pourquoi il a mis son
curseur là où il l'a mis et comme il a
dit sur plusieurs radios qui étaient
prêts les plus loin jusqu'où il peut
aller avec ce curseur merci merci
Monsieur
et bien je laisse la parole au ministre
au pluriel et dans l'ordre qu'il
souhaite
bien je vais essayer de répondre à ces
différentes interventions peut-être à
Monsieur Richard et donc à Madame boy en
même temps alors je vais répondre
évidemment celui-là isolé mais il faut
que vous sachiez mais vous le savez bien
sûr à la commission des lois que les
mineurs étrangers minorisés relèvent
strictement de la politique de la
compétence de garde des sceaux pour deux
raisons parce que il y a un sujet état
civil notamment pourquoi être l'identité
la question de savoir quel est l'état
civil des personnes et je ne suis pas le
ministre de l'état civil je regarde des
sauts à lire des dispositions dans la
justice qui arrivent sur justement cet
état civil notamment dans les pays en
guerre ou dans les pays qui auraient pu
les dativils ou l'établissement
fiabilisé et deuxièmement c'est que ce
n'est pas le Miss de l'Intérieur qui
expulse les mineurs c'est une décision
judiciaire qui relève de l'autorité
judiciaire en aucun cas autorité
administrative et donc en fait le
ministre de l'Intérieur après vous voyez
constate ses services qu'il s'agit d'un
mineur devant soi encore faut-il savoir
s'il est vraiment mineur ou pas mineur
donc la la la démarche qui consiste à
distinguer ces mineurs majeurs et du min
de l'intérieur une fois qu'on l'a
reconnu comme une heure il est de la
compétence directe de monsieur le garde
des sceaux et donc pour mettre fin au
flux et pour l'expulsion des personnes
qui sont mineures du territoire national
s'agissant de l'édition d'autorité
judiciaire il ne s'agit pas de l'action
du ministre de l'intérieur une fois que
je vous ai mis ses limites évidemment je
peux vous dire que effectivement nous
avons deux mesures qui nous permettent
de penser que ce texte va en très grande
partie permettre le travail au moins de
reconnaissance de la majorité de la
minorité le premier sujet c'est
évidemment la coercition sur les
empreintes puisque vous savez que l'un
des grands sujets c'est évidemment
l'identification des personnes dans
l'état civil que ces empreintes
aujourd'hui ne sont pas prises et que
les gens peuvent les refuser c'est
d'autant plus vrai s'il s'agit de gens
qui sont réputés mineurs j'entends la
demande qui est faite je crois par le
président Retailleau je l'ai vu ça
quelque part dans les journaux d'avoir
une présomption de majorité si le mineur
n'accède pas à aux demandes nombreuses
de tests tests évidemment de d'état
civil vous connaissez les tests osseux
mais qui sait bien qu'il ne fonctionne
pas dans tous les cas et ça c'est un
problème évidemment ou de coercition
évidemment des empreintes je crois que
le président lorsqu'il a formulé sa
proposition il ne savait pas que dans le
texte que nous proposions il y avait la
coercition des empreintes voilà qui
validait d'ailleurs par le Conseil
d'État je pense que l'un n'est pas
incompatible avec l'autre et que si le
Sénat veut rédiger quelque chose qui
ressemble à cela évidemment bien sûr
avec la difficulté constitutionnelle de
voir les choses acceptées je pense que
nous pourrions aller dans ce train
positif puisque nous mettons en place
avec le garde des sceaux une
expérimentation qui se termine à
Bordeaux qui est très intéressantes
puisque à Bordeaux le juge du parquet le
juge du siège le parquet et la police
s'est mis d'accord pour que les mineurs
ne passent plus de test mais qu'une
reconnaissance de majorité soit établie
par les policiers lorsque il les
interpellent dans le centre ville de
Bordeaux et que cette reconnaissance de
majorité qui est injuste qui est juste
la foi de l'OPJ dans son constat parce
qu'il voit que la personne a de la barbe
qu'il est développé enfin bref la
distinction entre la Major et un mineur
vaut reconnaissance pour le parquet pour
le siège et donc permet d'orienter du
côté de la sanction pénale
ce qu'ils étaient évidemment dans
l'espace du code des mineurs et surtout
permet la vie administrative du majeur
et non pas la vie judiciaire du mineur
donc je pense que cette base de travail
sur lequel nous travaillons sans texte
ni loi mais qui est reconnu par
l'autorité judiciaire peut aussi servir
dans la démarche que pour entreprendre
certains groupes du Sénat donc oui je
pense que ça permettra la reconnaissance
en tout cas plus efficace beaucoup plus
rapide non ça me permettra pas à
meilleur retour parce que l'un des
grands problèmes c'est le retour c'est
l'identification est-ce qu'il est
marocain est-ce qu'il est algérien ce
qui est tunisien puisque parfois ces
personnes mentent vous le savez bien sur
leur nationalité et nous travaillons
déjà à des reconnaissances puisqu'on
peut le faire parce que des policiers
Maroc algériens qui sont dans les
commissariats notamment à Paris parce
que nous regardons les données
téléphoniques pour regarder à qui ils
ont appelé sur leur téléphone portable
pour savoir s'ils ont appelé au Maroc ou
s'ils ont appelé en Algérie mais notre
problème n'est pas tellement
l'identification de 900 les deux mesures
nouvelles que je vous propose voir celle
que vous compléteriez que l'application
par l'autorité judiciaire et notamment
par les magistrats libres et
indépendants d'autres pays du retour
alors le garde des sauts à très
récemment signé une convention avec le
Maroc pour le retour il me semble mais
je pense qu'il reste pour le diable que
moi qu'il n'y a pas eu de décision
judiciaire positive pour le retour de
moi un mineur depuis cette convention
dans le dans le pays d'origine donc je
pense qu'il y a du point de vue du texte
garde des sceaux du texte protection de
l'enfance sans doute des choses qu'on ne
peut pas faire les intérieure puisqu'il
agit comme administratif donc oui pour
l'identification non pour le retour pour
répondre à la question très clairement
de sur Richard et Madame Boyer sur la
question de Monsieur Lecomte vous dites
bahiakar déjà qui d'après le Conseil
d'État c'est tout à fait vrai
ne sont pas dans qu'on prenne très le
français ça va donc dire que vous les
précariserez non mais ils vont retourner
dans leur pays monsieur le compte le but
du jeu c'est de pas donner les titres de
séjour aux gens qui parlent mal ou qui
qui comprennent pas le français donc ça
pour ça il y a une double condition il y
a un moyen plus important à mettre pour
l'État dans l'obligation de moyens donc
là ce que vous avez dit Monsieur du stop
c'est tout à fait important dans cette
révolution là c'est de dire que les gens
doivent prendre leur cours de français
désormais pendant leurs heures de
travail c'est une révolution aussi pour
l'étranger que aujourd'hui de prendre
des cours de français dès qu'elle est de
ces heures de travail donc quand vous
avez une femme de ménage qui fait une
heure de RER pour venir travailler qu'à
un ou deux enfants et qui doit faire une
heure de RER alors que le travail 5 ou 6
jours et parfois qui est irrégulière
dont exploité parce que un employeur qui
l'exploite on peut comprendre qu'elle
ait du mal à réussir son examen de
français ce serait pardon de dire comme
ça mais de dire il y a juste un
examen français et puis c'est tout nous
on dit il y a un examen de français qui
conditionne le titre de séjour mais il y
a aussi énormément de moyens que vont
désormais mettre en place les services
de la République pour que ces personnes
puissent suivre des cours de français le
temps qu'il faudra mais au bout d'un
moment on va demander l'examen de
français mais s'ils n'ont pas on va pas
précariser ces personnes ils n'auront
pas de titre de séjour et donc bah du
coup il repartiront dans leur pays je
savais qu'on nous assumons le fait que
le titre de séjour mais c'est dans ça
que c'est une révolution en partie ce
texte de loi et conditionné pas
simplement par le statut de la personne
par le fait qu'il ait le droit dans le
droit actuel de demander un titre de
séjour mais par le fait
ben écoutez c'est la proposition du
gouvernement
nous on trouve que pour s'intégrer et
notamment je pense
notamment pour les pour les femmes qui
d'ailleurs ont le moins accès à la
langue et moins en moins accès à notre
culture et qui parfois recréer du
communisme d'obligation d'obligation
elle le subissent bien évidemment parce
que la République ne sait pas intéressée
si je veux dire à les amener vers me
semble-t-il la plus belle langue du
monde pour se faire comprendre de
comprendre les idées de la République et
aller peut-être s'ouvrir s'ouvrir
l'esprit donc oui il va nous nous disons
que après les moyens très importants
qu'on y mettra après l'examen qu'on
imposera si les gens réussissent pas cet
examen et ça vaut pour les personnes qui
demandaient de ces jours comme pour ceux
qui m'ont demandé leur renouvellement y
compris pour les étrangers qui sont sur
notre sol je pense qu'il faut bien
comprendre que c'est une une révolution
importante dans le droit des étrangers
que la condition linguistique il y a des
pays qui le font il y a des pays qui le
font vous ne pouvez pas avoir certains
titres de ces jours longs dans un
certain pays anglo-saxons si vous n'avez
pas réussi un examen enfin je pense que
chacun le ici donc évidemment c'est une
disposition très importante et qui fait
des barres moi je comprends très bien et
qui est d'ailleurs assez novatrice en
Europe sur les moyens des préfectures
bon on aura l'occasion d'en discuter
mais ça renforcement de 570 agents que
vous allez voter dans la dans la loopy
mais aussi particulièrement je voudrais
le dire des travaux à la fois
informatique la fameuse annaf pour ceux
qui s'intéressent au fonctionnement de
la Direction générale des étrangers en
France qui sera beaucoup plus efficace
et les ETP les personnes qui aujourd'hui
font tout le travail que j'ai expliqué
de répétition qui n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt pour la République pour se
concentrer sur les personnes qui ont
plus besoin d'être avant d'être
contrôlés et non monsieur le sénateur
pardon si je me suis mal exprimé mais il
n'y a pas avec le guida avec la cellule
nouvelle il n'y a pas de moments où
l'étranger ne passe plus devant les
associations pour raconter leur récit il
y aura toujours ce moment évidemment et
ce sera toujours le parcours du
demandeur du demandeur d'asile donc on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler mais je me
pour assurer sur ce point sur les LR bon
les ras vous savez sont connus dans
votre dans votre département il suffit
de préfet c'est du listes publiée
d'ailleurs j'ai du mal à comprendre
pourquoi vous dites que le LR1 n'est pas
ça pose un problème sur la liberté
publique parce que c'est Monsieur j'ose
pas que les a créé le 19 mars 2001 par
décret voilà donc c'est pas un
gouvernement de droite ou le nôtre qui
pourrait être considéré comme étant
particulièrement factieux je pense que
si Monsieur Jospin crée les ras c'est
que il lui considérer que ça devait être
républicain et conforme conforme aux
droits et puis enfin pour Ethias moi est
en train de sortir Schengen moi je
voudrais itère le fait que nous on est
totalement prêt on peut le faire demain
matin simplement c'est pas vous que je
vais apprendre que l'Europe c'est pas
que la France il y a plusieurs pays qui
sont pas toujours aussi au rendez-vous
que nous notamment nous avons un
problème vous le savez bien avec nos
amis britanniques qui avaient engagé en
trésident des Schengen et puis entre
temps ils sont devenus un pays tiers
donc ça va poser problème et notamment
au port de Louvre j'en parle beaucoup
avec mon homologue britannique puisqu'en
plus par ailleurs le port de nous venait
pas une propriété direct du gouvernement
britannique et donc ça passe par une
délégation enfin bref un peu complexe
pour mettre en place le système entrée
sur des Schengen nous avons dit à la
Commission européenne avec Clément bonne
nous avons dit soit on le fait
rapidement donc nous on est prêt et donc
ça veut dire rapidement c'est à dire
quoi c'est à dire sans doute après la
Coupe du monde de rugby soit on le fait
après les JO parce que qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on fait l'entrée sortie
Schengen on crée une fiche biométrique
pour chacune des personnes qui va entrer
sur le sol européen c'est à dire 10
minutes au minimum
à l'Aubette donc la veille ou l'avant
veille en juin juillet 2023 on va pas
s'amuser à faire 10 minutes par personne
dans les aéroports parisiens alors qu'on
va faire revenir des millions et des
millions de personnes non seulement pour
la vie touristique du pays mais pour les
JO donc ça ce serait thrombose assurée
donc nous on dit on est prêt on le fait
maintenant si on le fait pas maintenant
on se rappelle juste après la Coupe du
monde de rugby parce qu'il faut accepter
l'arrivée des gens pendant de rugby mais
si c'est pour nous dire que les pays
seront prêts en juin 2024 la France dira
non on attendra après après les JO donc
après septembre 2024 donc on redit et on
a redit à la Commission européenne je
fais ces interventions régulièrement un
Conseil européen que nous nous sommes
prêts que nous attendons les autres et
on bouge la Commission française avait
vu qui a été nommée qui a été élu à
l'agence ulisa qui c'est tout à fait
conscient des difficultés des autres de
certains autres pays pour Madame
l'herbier moi je peux être que d'accord
avec vous même Verbier tant sur la
question de l'ordre public et peut-être
je serai monsieur du stop dire un mot
sur la deuxième point sur la vie
professionnelle et sur la vie étudiante
mais vous avez parfaitement raison et
notamment sur les liens avec les pays
producteurs de drogue et qui sont au
trafiquants de drogue on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler sans doute madame stage
joyeux vous posez une question en tout
cas si me concerne sur l'accord et je
terminerai par là plus la question de
Bresse sur l'accord sur les accords
bilatéraux prenons l'accord
franco-algérien c'est une question très
intéressante auquel je me suis beaucoup
intéressé je comprends pourquoi vous
nous dites l'accord franco-algérien qui
grosso modo est un accord fait entre nos
pays en 68 qui prévoit des avances des
avantages et des inconvénients entre la
de de discussion avec l'Algérie sur les
questions migratoires
avantages pour les Algériens une carte
de résidence spécifique que chacun
connaît avec des droits particuliers qui
sont reconnus aux citoyens algériens
inconvénient il y a des visas
tous les pays comme les pays tiers n'ont
pas forcément de visa que demande la
partie algérienne la même chose que vous
le parlement algérien demande parfois
l'abolition de l'accord franco-algérien
mais pas pour les mêmes raisons parce
que
Ie leur ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas de
visa pour venir en France on sait bien
pourquoi il a été fait il a été fait un
moment donné où la France devait tirer
des conclusions des accords d'Évian
jusqu'au bout du fait que l'Algérie
n'était plus la France et donc avoir un
lion un lien particulier avec non
seulement nos amis algériens mais aussi
tous ceux qui avaient des intérêts des
avantages des propriétés dans les
conditions très tumultueuses de
l'histoire entre la France et l'Algérie
il faut être deux pays
donc il faudrait que nous renégocions un
accord il faut que les deux parties
signent cet accord aujourd'hui l'actuel
qui a été droit je me suis beaucoup
intéressé à cette question si nous
mettons fin à l'accord franco-algérien
ils ont en imaginant que la France signe
et explique que c'est plus possible nous
reviendrons dans une communauté ou nous
ne pourrions plus demander de visa aux
ressortissants algérien pour venir sur
notre sol puisque avant l'accord
photographe
elle est pas d'accord puisque nous
étions dans une même communauté
nationale
oui mais si nous revenons non mais
écoutez bah écoutez ce sont les très
nombreuses je suis beaucoup intéressé à
cette question je peux vous dire que
l'ensemble des notes de notre diplomatie
confirmé par malheureusement une grande
partie de ceux qui sont extérieurs à
d'autres pays mais qui regardent des
agorat internationaux que dans très
particulier de l'Algérie je pense que
nous aurions aujourd'hui plus certains
qui a gagné en revanche qu'il faille
renégocier l'accord il appartient en
chef d'État de le faire avec l'autorité
du Parlement bien évidemment c'est une
question que tout le monde se pose du
côté algérien comme du côté français à
chaque fois qu'on nous rencontrons nos
homologues il nous en parle et ça fait
très longtemps il a été plusieurs fois
modifié cet accord on peut penser qu'il
y a des avenants qui peuvent
profondément modifier ses accords la
seule difficulté c'est est-ce qu'ils ont
le fait dans des conditions de communion
politique on va dire que le Président de
la République essaye de faire avec le
président teboun où est-ce qu'on le fait
dans une confrontation bon ça c'est une
décision politique qui n'appartient pas
au ministre mise à l'intérieur pour
Monsieur de Bresse il n'y a pas de
disposition de restriction du logement
familial dans notre projet de loi
cependant j'ai eu l'occasion alors sauf
à considérer que évidemment la langue
s'applique et donc ces cas-là ça touche
évidemment la langue j'ai entendu la
part de beaucoup de sénateurs du groupe
centriste et du groupe LR proposé des
restrictions d'abord je voulais vous
dire qu'en attendant le débat sénatorial
le gouvernement a pris soin à ce qu'il y
ait des accroches pour que le Parlement
puisse déposer des amendements qui
prévoit sur restriction je saurai
favorable assez à un moment appartement
évidemment il respecte les principes
conventionnels et constitutionnels mais
je crois que sénateur ne ferait pas
autre chose que de respecter la
Constitution et la convention moi
personnellement je vois trois endroits
dans lequel le Sénat pourrait aller le
premier endroit c'est celui qu'on a tous
vécu quand on était maire c'est-à-dire
les conditions d'accueil du groupement
familial pour accueillir des gens
familiales je sais pas si vous faisiez
ça que vous étiez mère Monsieur le Maire
mais moi quand j'étais mère je le
faisais je signais moi-même ce que les
citoyens étrangers venaient demander à
la à la mairie et attester que leur
logement était assez grand qui est
touché au moins euros pour une famille
de deux personnes et que effectivement
ils avaient une situation stable depuis
18 mois sur le territoire national je
suis pas sûr que tous les maires de
France entre deux soi-dis regardent
expressément cela il faut comme savoir
que pour donner des titres de
regroupement familial la préfecture
s'appuie sur le document délivré par la
mairie la question d'ailleurs de savoirs
sont gêner les représentants des
collectivités locales peut-être est-ce
quelque chose que les mairies peuvent
pas dans certaines conditions faire bon
c'est une question que l'on peut qu'on
peut se poser en tout cas nous délivrons
du repas familial que lorsque les maires
en tout cas leur service attestent de ce
document la question se pose si ce
document doit être mieux vérifié
premièrement petit veut dire double un
double contre ça afin que ça risque de
préfecture empêche ici le clientélisme
électoral là la difficulté de dire non à
une famille que l'on connaît quand on
est élu bon c'est une question qu'on a
eu sur les lieux de culte dans d'autres
circonstances et deuxièmement est-ce que
1800 euros pour deux personnes ça suffit
et est-ce que le logement à taille
suffisante c'est assez suffisant pour
être défini dans la loi
parce que quand on accueille quelqu'un
de l'extérieur ça paraît pas anormal de
demander peut-être davantage de revenus
ou peut-être davantage de commodité ou
davantage de présence sur le territoire
national donc si le Sénat allait vers
des modifications qui diraient un
logement plus grand des rémunérations
plus forte et surtout une condition de
présence plus longue sur le territoire
national ça me paraîtrait de bon sens et
non contraire à la Constitution à la
convention à la grosseur européenne des
droits de l'homme mais peut-être les
limiter le repas familial le deuxième
sujet c'est que pour ceux qui
bénéficient de la protection
internationale il y a des possibilités
de regroupement familial de
réunification familiale comme on dit en
droit mais qui vont loin c'est-à-dire
que c'est pas simplement les frères et
soeurs il se peut que y ait des gens
dans une conception très large de la
famille les demi-frères les demi-sœurs
des voilà des gens qui peut-être sont un
peu loin de la vision familiale telle
que le droit français défini qui sont
acceptés et quand on donne l'asile à
quelqu'un faut-il le donner alors qu'on
donne à sa famille ça me paraît pas
choquant bien évidemment faut-il donner
à sa famille au sens très large du terme
je pense que si le Sénat parce que j'ai
eu depuis quelques mois m'intéressait à
la question de ce projet de loi des abus
incontestablement considéré qu'il
fallait limiter son bon familial à la
stricte famille en défense en
définissant c'est quoi la famille au
sens français du terme je pense que nous
y gagnerions et nous limiterions ainsi
cette difficulté mais le troisième sujet
il me semble que ça pourrait être
l'attestation linguistique ou
l'attestation des valeurs de la
République y compris pour ceux qui ont
des visas de roulement familial puisque
aujourd'hui vous demandez à quelqu'un
la langue et le respect des vers de la
République mais quand il sera là depuis
18 mois et qu'il aura un logement
suffisant 1800 euros de revenus et un
accompagnement
comment dirais-je de
présence sur le territoire national de
18 mois vous demandez pas à ces à sa
femme à son mari à ses parents à ses
enfants les mêmes exigences est-ce que
le Sénat pourrait dire bah voilà on
demande là aussi le la langue et là
aussi les valeurs de la République quoi
donc ça ça me paraît de notre point de
vue des dispositions qui pourraient
limiter le groupement familial sans être
contraire à la Constitution contraire à
la croix
certains autres pays par exemple
[Musique]
la réponse sur les jeunes
ma question sur les mineurs isolés
c'était sur l'accès à la nationalité
française alors que ces personnes sont
rentrées via des trafiquants d'êtres
humains sont en situation irrégulière
sont à la charge des départements
parfois au détriment je dois dire des
enfants que nous devons prendre en
charge de l'enfance de l'enfance en
souffrance maltraitée donc je voudrais
savoir si dans le projet de loi vous
allez faire en sorte que ces personnes
ne puissent pas accéder comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui quasi pas
automatiquement mais très fréquemment à
la nationalité française une fois qu'ils
sont majeurs alors j'ai pas répondu à la
fois deuxième question de la nostalgie
vous en aviez trois les mineurs je
conservé alors moi j'ai pas de
connaissances de de mineur qui est
arrivé à l'âge majeur deviennent
français quasi le systématiquement donc
en revanche qui disait quasi
systématiquement des des titres de
séjour parce que ils sont depuis un
certain temps sur le territoire national
c'est tout à fait vrai d'ailleurs le
président du conseil départemental de
l'Essonne m'a interpellé sur difficulté
de la loi dite taquet des personnes qui
désormais venu mineur isolé non
seulement le département doit les
protéger mais que pour les deux années
qui suivent leur minorité ils doivent
désormais aussi puisqu'une sorte de
difficulté à l'attaquer le Conseil
d'État a fait une décision qui
appliquent la loi donc ça pose un
problème donc je pense que c'est plus
une question mon avis de titre de séjour
quasiment donné en attendant une
éventuelle expulsion je ne l'ai pas en
tête madame satrice mais si vous avez
des cages je les regarderai bien je me
permets de vous le dire parce que j'ai
fait un rapport lorsque j'étais député
sur ce sujet et les départements
interrogés m'ont dit qu'ils
accompagnaient pour qu'ils accèdent
je veux pas dire systématiquement parce
que c'est peut-être le terme est trop
trop
enfin pour qu'ils accèdent le plus
rapidement possible la nationalité
française
très bien volontiers peut-être sur la
deuxième question madame la sénatrice
monsieur le Président sur les passeurs
donc merci de nous remercier de
reprendre votre proposition je pense que
contre les passeurs tout est bonnes
volontés sont bonnes je voudrais dire
qu'on crée une circonstance aggravante
générale donc ça ne concerne pas que les
personnes que vous évoquez ça concerne
vraiment au sens large tous les passeurs
y compris les les complices y compris ce
qui exploite je vois d'ailleurs dire
dans le Sénat que nous avons créé un
office de préjudiciaire spécifique qu'on
appelle l'autre lime avec 140 officiers
de police judiciaires c'est vraiment à
mon avis pour dire que l'application du
droit sera faite grâce à cette office et
puis enfin
je voudrais dire à Madame sabriniaux que
sur la question des médecins qui
n'appliqueraient pas la loi eux-mêmes
l'article
412,7 que nous créons dans l'article 13
du projet de loi est extrêmement clair
l'étranger qui sollicite un document de
séjour s'engage à respecter la liberté
personnelle la liberté d'expression et
de conscience l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes la dignité de la personne
humaine la devise et les symboles de la
République au sens de l'article de la
Constitution et à ne pas se prévaloir de
ses croyances de convictions pour
s'affranchir des règles communes
régissant les relations entre les
services publics et les particuliers ça
concerne tout le monde les patients
comme les médecins
merci monsieur le Président peut-être de
manière télégraphique sur trois points
d'abord pour dire que pour ce qui
concerne les plateformes et plus
largement que les plateformes la
question des auto-entrepreneurs et des
entreprises individuelles c'est un vrai
c'est une vraie faille que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et il n'est pas
acceptable que des personnes en
situation irrégulière puissent d'une
certaine manière créer une entreprise
individuelle ou se créer comme
auto-entrepreneur et ainsi exercer une
activité qui devient régulière pourquoi
ça n'est pas acceptable parce que
lorsque les personnes concernées pour
une raison pour une autre son objet d'un
OCP délivré par les services de ministre
de l'Intérieur il est devient logique à
la fois pour la personne concernée et
parfois pour les juges qui sont amenés à
examiner tel ou tel recours de dire que
l'État ne peut pas prétendre ne pas
connaître découvrir la situation
irrégulière sur le territoire de tel ou
telle personne alors que dans le même
temps par l'existence d'une entreprise
individuelle il y a eu perception de
cotisation et régulièrement aussi
d'impôt sur le revenu du fait du
prélèvement à la source forfaitaire en
tout cas des avances forfaitaires
prévues dans le cadre du prélèvement à
la source donc c'est une vraie volonté
de tarir un flux qui nourrit cette
situation de personnes en situation
irrégulière mais avec l'exercice d'une
activité régulière beaucoup d'entre eux
notamment pour les auto-entrepreneurs
sont concernés au peuvent être concernés
par le travail de plateforme et en
réalité derrière la question des
plateformes dans ce domaine là il y a
deux sujets il y a le sujet des
personnes en situation irrégulière dans
la plateforme découvre l'irrégularité de
la situation et procède à une
déconnexion et il y a peut-être de
manière plus régulière encore plus
fréquente des personnes qui en réalité
exercent un travail sur une plateforme
non pas en situation irrégulière sur le
papier si je peux dire mais avec des
alias ce qui renvoie aussi à d'autres
difficultés pour accompagner cela nous
avons malgré tout des charges sociales
avec les plateformes pour que la
déconnexion puisse être annoncée et
accompagner autant que possible mais les
personnes qui sont en situation
régulière le reste elle doit faire
l'objet d'un traitement de leur
situation en fonction de la régularité
de leur séjour et des causes
d'irrégularité de l'irrégularité et
lorsqu'ils sont pour nous de laisser
perdurer la possibilité de créer une
entreprise ou une auto-entreprise pour
des personnes qui n'ont pas de raison
d'être sur le territoire vous avez
évoqué la question de la circulaire
valse monsieur Lecomte celle-ci concerne
pour à peu près 7000 cas par an des
admissions exceptionnelles au séjour
pour des motifs économiques avec des
caractéristiques qui peuvent recouper
une partie de ceux et celles qui sont
concernées par l'article 3 tel que nous
prévoyons mais pour 22 à 23000 cas ce
sont des admissions exceptionnelles de
séjour pour des motifs familiaux qui
sont prononcés dans le cadre de la
circulaire basse c'est la raison pour
laquelle les deux dispositifs ne sont
pas nécessairement antagoniques par
contre ça me fait un lien avec les
interrogations de Madame sajignon la
circulaire valse aujourd'hui c'est 7000
régularisations pour des activités
économiques dans la moitié en
Île-de-France et comme je disais tout à
l'heure à Monsieur benka et Madame
Jourda il vaut mieux à nos yeux que la
reconnaissance du droit à un séjour et
donc la régularisation de travailleurs
en situation irrégulière mais ayant une
activité professionnelle régulière sur
le territoire soit déterminé par des
critères fixés et définis par
législateur plutôt que par des critères
qui à l'exception des critères
d'ancienneté tels qu'ils sont prévus
dans la circulaire relèvent d'une
appréciation discrétionnaire préfecture
par préfecture et c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs cette appréciation
discrétionnelle motivée par les
difficultés inhérentes à chaque
territoire qui explique que la moitié
des cas sont concentrés sur la région
parisienne alors que nous savons qu'il y
a des difficultés pareils vous m'avez
ensuite interrogé madame la sénatrice
sur la question des métiers de tension
et vous m'avez dit mais finalement dans
un territoire comme le mien tous les
métiers sont en tension et d'une
certaine manière je vous le confirme je
vous le confirme par un autre
raisonnement vous n'imaginez pas le
nombre de fédérations professionnelles
qui nous contactent qui nous contactent
directement pour s'inquiéter et
s'assurer que leur métier sera bien dans
la liste
ce à quoi je réponds que ce n'est pas
nous qui allons décider des mettez dans
la liste mais bien l'appareil
statistique avec la définition d'un
niveau de tension et donc la liste des
métiers en tension existe elle a été
créée par la loi il y a plusieurs années
elle fait l'objet d'une publication
régulière et nous allons lancer ce
processus de révision qui s'appuie sur
les crews comme tes régionaux pour
l'emploi la formation professionnelle et
sur l'appareil statistique du ministère
pour tenir compte à la fois des
difficultés de recrutement et de la
présence parfois très forte d'étrangers
non communautaire qui justifient parfois
une tension un peu moindre mais sans la
présence de cette manœuvre nos
communautaire la tension serait au-delà
de l'attention et ça serait une
incapacité pour le secteur de
fonctionner il y a des demandes des
fédérations professionnelles dans la
matière il y a des demandes
d'organisation syndicales les trois
principales pour nous citer que les
premières dans leur protocolaire la CFDT
la CGT Force Ouvrière souhaite même que
les travailleurs qui exercent dans des
secteurs économiques pas nécessairement
attention face au lieu d'une
régularisation de plein droit c'est pas
vers ce n'est pas
que nous allons puisque nous fixons un
certain nombre de critères mais il y a
vraiment une volonté partagée de
faciliter y compris c'est parcours de
régularisation et nous essayons de poser
des critères pour que ce soit lisibles
et évaluable par le Parlement vous avez
ensuite fait deux remarques la première
concernant
le fait que les métiers les secteurs
seraient de moins en tension si les
rémunérations étaient ajustées à la
hausse or il se trouve que un des
secteurs les plus intentions et au sein
duquel nous avons le plus de demandes
pour élargir la liste des métiers
concernés au sein du secteur un secteur
qui s'exprime j'ai parlé de lui MIH tout
à l'heure pour dire allons plus loin en
matière de régularisation et facilitant
facilitant en plus les procédures
d'entrée sur le territoire de nouveaux
étrangers non communautaire pour occuper
des métiers dans notre secteur c'est
justement un secteur le secteur
hôtellerie qui a fait restauration dans
lequel la négociation des partenaires
sociaux a amené leur valorisation des
minimum conventionnels la plus forte
c'est 16% à l'issue de la période de
covid des tensions de recrutement qui
sont intervenus maintenant un peu plus
d'un an le secteur HCR dans sa
négociation collective a augmenté les
niveaux de rémunération conventionnelle
de 16%. et c'est malgré tout ce secteur
qui concentre peut-être parmi les plus
fortes difficultés de tension et qui
nous dans les interpellations dont nous
ont l'objet et le plus demandeur en
matière de régularisation
d'accompagnement et je le répète de
possibilités supplémentaire d'entrer sur
le territoire ce que nous n'avons pas
envisager envisager à ce stade enfin il
y a un dernier point j'en termine par là
vous vous craignez que cette possibilité
de régularisation par le quelques
milliers de personnes par an ça n'est
pas quelque chose gigantesque mais que
cette régularisation soit une forme de
trappe à Bassel je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure en réponse à Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs je pense que c'est tout
l'inverse que c'est le fait d'être en
situation irrégulière sur un territoire
qui rend vulnérable notamment face à des
employeurs qui ne sont pas tous très
attentifs ou très délicat je cherche les
mots les plus adéquates nous avons des
cas c'est très pragmatique mais dont
nous sommes saisis de salariés qui sont
employés sur des contrats temps partiel
à mi-temps qui sont payés à mi-temps et
qui en réalité travaillent beaucoup plus
mais étant en situation irrégulière sur
le territoire et n'ayant que cet emploi
déclaré si je peux dire son contrat
d'accepter cette situation et le fait de
pouvoir donner une sécurité juridique à
la fois l'employeur parce que je le
répète bien souvent l'employeur ne sait
pas la situation irrégulière sans
salarié et aux salariés ça garantit
l'application des minimum des niveaux de
rémunération conventionnelle ça garantit
évidemment l'application du salaire
minimum et c'est plutôt avec un effet
inverse à l'attrape à bas salaire par
rapport au maintien d'un certain nombre
de personnes dans des situations qu'on
peut qualifier comme des situations de
vulnérabilité et donc c'est vraiment
avec cet objectif là que nous
travaillons et j'espère que les débats
que nous aurons dans l'hémicycle
permettront d'en convaincre maximum
merci Monsieur le Ministre bien écoutez
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
et je crois qu'il y en a eu beaucoup en
tous les cas et beaucoup d'explications
nous arrivons en termes de notre
commission il me reste à vous remercier
messieurs pour votre présence rappelez
au commissaire que la Commission nous
rapporteur présent leur rapport le 15 en
commission le 15 mars et que la séance
aura lieu à partir du 27 exactement du
28 qui est un mardi sur ma part enfin je
vous redonne rendez-vous à tous les
commissaires aux lois demain matin à 9h
dans notre salle de réunion préférée
merci à vous et bonne soirée merci